this is jaco podcast number 346 with
dave burke and me jocko willink good
evening dave good evening
in an airplane
the guy was a mongoose
it's hard to believe if the only bud
anderson you ever knew was the one on
the ground
calm
gentlemanly a grandfather funny
an all-around nice guy
but once you get him in an airplane he's
vicious
shot down 17
best fighter pilot i've ever seen
he's also the best friend i have in the
world
we go back 47 years andy and i
andy and i developed a rapport flying
mustangs in england particularly after i
was shot down made my way back and
finally got the okay to finish my tour
we were both small town boys who liked
hunting and fishing
we kept finding things in common and
developed a tremendous mutual respect
by the time we finished up and went home
we were pretty damn close although
making friends wasn't something either
of us went out of our way to do it was
risky in wartime
we lost an awful lot of guys over there
we had the same kind of eyes 2010.
we saw everything that went on in the
sky before anyone else in the squadron
or even the group
what made andy unique was that he flew
so many missions logged so many combat
hours
and never had a battle damage or aborted
mission
an incredible record
it shows what a meticulous professional
he is especially in combat
the same attention to detail is what
made him a hell of a test pilot
he had those eyes too and he developed
the combat skills to take advantage of
the opportunities his eyes brought him
but luck was also a part of it
luck plays a big part in anything you do
in combat
some guy you don't see can always sneak
up and shoot your ass off
no question
andy is a very very lucky guy
anyone who got through the war was
generally speaking getting killed was
the least of our worries
when it happens
you don't know anything about it anyway
so what the hell
that's the attitude i think that most of
us had
duty was paramount
damn it it's your job
the fact that you might get killed
doesn't enter your mind after the first
couple times
and so those right there are
words
written by chuck yeager
probably the most famous and legendary
fighter pilot of all time
and the words are written in the forward
of a book called to fight to fly and
fight
by colonel clarence budd
anderson who chuck yeager refers to as
andy
now bud anderson was a fighter pirate
pilot in world war ii
and in vietnam he was a triple ace
which means he shot down more than 15
enemy aircraft
he was a test pilot
when being a test pilot meant you were
the best of the best
he ended up serving over 30 years in
uniform
and it is an honor to have him with us
here tonight to discuss his experiences
and lessons learned
sir
thank you so much for joining us it's an
honor to have you here
it was my pleasure jacob
that's uh quite the praise from general
jaeger you got there
he wrote it
[Laughter]
uh
so i guess we can jump into this
i know i know you were born uh january
13th 1922.
and right now the date is
august 3rd
which means you got the you got the
triple digits in your age
up there at 100
[Laughter]
that's pretty impressive what's the keys
to your health
no mind or vices
there you go
that'll do it
um you've got some kind of just to get
to know you a little bit uh i want to
read a little section from the book here
and it says i was the third of my
father's four children born january 13th
1922 in oakland where my mom's parents
lived friday the 13th it was if it's an
unlucky day you couldn't prove it by me
i've been pretty lucky i never was
superstitious
it says clarence a meal is that right
emil
anderson jr on my birth certificate
but few call me clarence or junior and
none call me a mill
when i was young my family nicknamed me
buddy which in time became bud
the men i flew with used andy because
all andersons are automatically andy
i can attest to that
the first thing i remember is lindbergh
making it across the atlantic when he
when i was just five i have no idea why
somebody flying from one place to
another should have made such a lasting
impression but it kindled an interest in
airplanes that would last a lifetime
when i was seven my father took me to
sacramento to a little dirt airfield
with one little hangar where a fellow
named ing
valdezquad
made or supplemented his living by
taking people up for rides in a steerman
biplane
the airfield was on auburn boulevard
near watt avenue
i can remember being excited and a
little bit frightened the incredible
intoxicating smell of the gasoline oil
and airplane dope like a new car smell
and the throaty sound of the engine
most of all i remember flying over our
house and circling tightly the pilot
standing the plane on its side
it's a pretty awesome introduction to
aviation
the
a biplane was the first thing you flew
in huh yes and so that's just a big
giant open cockpit
was your dad with you or is only a
two-seater yeah it was a three-seater
okay yeah
you know the pilot in the back and then
side-by-side
[Music]
in seats
front
and he buzzed your house yeah
so you could say your dad is partially
to blame for your fascination with
flying he supported my
my uh
likes
so what did you what did your
mom and dad do when you were growing up
uh well i grew up on a farm and that's
what we did
we farmed
and that means you were probably working
more than most people work in their
lives yeah i had uh
yeah pretty heavy
chores
and then later on
as a depression
um hit
my mom had to go
and
go to go back to work
and she went and found a
job in the
governor's office
and she was just a typist and everything
and then worked her way up to office
manager
and then it was it was in the old days a
spoil system
so when a new governor came in they
fired everybody
and then
they kept her to
to um
you know tie in got it
and then pretty soon they
they
dropped her salary and everything
but suddenly soon they uh
said why don't you stay
brought her salary back up
and then she went through about four
governors like that
pretty pretty awesome
yeah i mean
for the depression and being in a farmer
during the depression yeah how rough was
that for for the family
well
at least we we didn't
suffer too bad from food because we
manufactured food
right raised chickens and um
grew
lots of vegetables and fruit of course
so a lot of canning
and
[Music]
so as a kid i don't remember being
hungry at any time wow
well that's a definitely a good uh
family business to have during the
depression being a farmer
and so but you still had to go to school
right oh yeah and i know you played you
played sports in school
i was
i liked basketball but i was kind of
small
so i could only play on the c and the
b meetings
i could never go to the varsity
uh
but it sounds like you know in the book
you talk about sounds like your dad not
only encourage you with flying but he
put a lot of
he put a lot of
it seemed like he put a lot of trust in
you even as a young kid a lot of
responsibility i know you
and you know i get asked a lot of
questions about parenting
and at one point you crashed your car
how'd that happen
oh
young and
young and scared
hit the wrong pedal yeah yeah well
as you came up
uh you can't see that here but there
there's a double road at the
front door
and it always went on the inner inner
road you know
and uh so i came around the corner
he's he's behind the wheel
and i'm over here
staring and
you know with a foot pedal
too and so i come up to
go down the road and hope it's blocked
by a car
so i said oh
i gotta i gotta get over here in the
left and get on my bypass and
and a big
tree was coming up
and i
went to the middle and pushed down on
the accelerator and tucked my head under
the
dash i think and dad was
he was trying to get me to
get out of here you know but
i was
i don't know it's just a bad bad thing
but the interesting thing is how he kind
of handled that you know he kind of got
you right back on the horse as they said
well yeah you know how
if you go through a
terrifying experience
uh it's best to get them back on
back online
now speaking of terrifying experiences
for someone that has aspirations of
being a pilot
i know there was a plane crash
that took place in your hometown
how did that impact you and how did that
steer you away from wanting to be a
pilot well
i had a buddy down in loomis nearby town
and
he and i were
just kind of nuts about anything
aviation is this jack yeah jack stacker
and so uh
this was something we had to investigate
personally
and it was an old boeing
biplane three engine biplane
and he crashed in
on the side of a hill
not too heavy
down well you know it was a whole
fuselage was there
and the other parts
kind of were in the area
and uh
so we just had to we just had to see
what it was like
yeah and i guess in those days there's
no black box there's no real way to tell
what had even gone wrong no
but you looked at that and said
still seems like a good
seems like a good job i want well
maybe we want to fly fighters
[Laughter]
uh
so i'm gonna and by the way i'm i'm
gonna read some chunks of the book the
book is fantastic uh get just order the
book right now it's just an incredible
book there's so many details in it
um i'm gonna fast forward a little bit
you say right after graduation i was
working out in the yard when a car came
chattering into the drive a fellow
climbed out extended his hand showed me
his teeth and started telling me in a
practice salesman's pitch about this
trade school in down down in los angeles
or someplace
he said they could teach me all about
refrigeration a good solid career and he
pulled a bunch of brochures from his bag
i'm thinking how college would have been
nice but i've got to do something and
then dad came around the corner
we hadn't talked much about the future
we talked more about arthur j lewis the
several months previous than we had ever
talked about my future
but there and then in the yard i learned
that my dad was pretty shrewd and
supportive go on get out of here he told
the salesman gruffly my boy's going to
college and then he's going into the
army air corps
so
he
you he was convinced that this is what
you were going to do you know
and he was fully supportive
i think it was the other way around
[Laughter]
uh
fast forward a little bit you say there
were three requirements for enlisting in
the army air corps beyond passing the
physical you needed two years of college
i figured to complete the course in june
1941 you had to be at least 20 years old
which i would be on january 13th 1942
and you had to be single
which seemed simple enough since i had
no good prospects
this course of study would qualify me
and if it turned out i couldn't fly for
some reason then at least i could fix or
build airplanes
so that's what you're thinking you're
focused on getting into the army air
corps there's some
pretty minimal requirements really to go
and enlist
i mean not being married sounds like you
were trying the field but hadn't turned
anything out yet
so you were all right there
when you're physical with something you
you know your eyes
[Music]
did you know when they gave you the
physical that your eyes were awesome
um i can't remember i think maybe
we did go get a air dock to give me a
flight physical
i don't really
i don't really remember
you end up um taking flying lessons so
you're learning how to fly
and you you say this my instructor dale
hunter was an old guy
24 maybe
i don't remember that learning was
terribly difficult on the daily rating
sheets there were 36 descriptive words
or phrases some positive some otherwise
all or none of which the instructor
could check after each lesson
the four he marked after my first flight
march 4th 1941 wore
cooperative
rough on controls careful poor
coordination
on march 27th the day that i soloed he
put a mark by erratic
by the end of may
uh after 37 hours in the cub
he would check only eager to learn and
consistent
i don't remember a lot of compliments
but i soloed after the standard eight
hours of instruction did everything
pretty much by the numbers got my
license no problem
so there you go you're learning how to
fly pretty
pretty quick it seems like
yeah i was
what i guess
17 or 18.
it was a government program
uh
civilian pilot training program
and with no commitment no
financial i think it was a
insurance policy for my parents and nine
dollars and fifty cents
and
and uh
was a pretty good deal so i globbed on
to it while i was going to
uh junior college so so what year was
that that you soloed for the first time
41.
so that was 1941 yeah so spring
so when did so when did pearl harbor
happen so it happened december 7th yeah
so you were already flying but you
weren't old enough to enlist yet correct
and uh
uh
we were i went to work
like my college training
qualified me to be an aircraft mechanic
it was a technical school
part of a two-year thing
and
the sacramento air depot was building up
as a dipple
and they were hiring anybody that said
they could turn a wrench i think
they hired our whole class
and um
this was after pearl harbor they hired
your whole class uh right at graduation
oh our graduation graduation six months
before got it pile harbor
and i can remember to this day
well every guy world war ii guy knows
where he was december 7th
and we were working 24 7.
and being the kids young guys they
put us on the graveyard shift
and i'd just gotten on days
and
i remember sunday
uh
came around later in the day
and said hey you you you
go home and come back at midnight the
chaps will just attack us at pearl
harbor
god i didn't even know where pearl
harbor was
but i knew the impact of that was
uh oh we're at war
and
i was still
uh 19
and so i had to wait one month
i went down on my birthday
and a few days later
i
raised my right hand and i was on my way
you say in the book on the 13th of
january my 20th birthday i went in to
sign up they had a recruiting office
right there on base they gave me a
physical and i was so keyed up with
anticipation that they gave me the
schneider test a blood pressure and
pulse check the doctor said it was
borderline there might be a problem my
heart was pounding away like a
jackhammer i was told to come back in a
couple days and they'd test me again
after i was accepted i couldn't wait to
tell lloyd geraldson an older guy who'd
been a pilot and done some barnstorming
he worked at the depot and we often
carpooled together i looked up to him
liked to listen to him talk about flying
i told him the moment he got in the car
and he leaned back against the
passenger's door and stared at me
silently
son he said after a while let me tell
you something
you've just signed your own death
warrant
that's a heavy statement
yeah
years later
we we talked about it years later and he
said he doesn't remember saying that
he was just throwing it out there it it
had a little impact on me but not much
uh so then you start flight training
yeah and it was all the flight training
down in san diego
just my primary okay
so you go down there and from the book
it sounds like you you already knew how
to fly so got a private pilot's license
did that make it just a lot easier than
the other people were having i
don't remember having any trouble
going through the military
flight training schools
just easy dave was that you too
i did not have the license going to
flight school so i had a slightly
different experience
but um i know that the folks that had
some flight experience getting to flight
school it could actually be a
double-edged sword if you brought some
bad habits but most of those kids showed
up
understood things that i didn't
understand so i definitely had to catch
up to the ones that had experience
check
uh
was it a big deal like being a fighter
pilot i remember my dad telling me when
you know when he was a kid that even
like an airline pilot
people treated airline pilots like they
were superstars like they were rock
stars and now obviously that like the
dave burke here he grew up in the top
gun era where everybody knew what a
fighter pilot was
what was the
kind of what was the the the aura around
fighter pilots back then
i don't
i don't think there was too much
of that
to tell you the truth
probably
just pilot maybe yeah
so you guys were busy creating the aura
that guys like dave burke would get to
live off of
so you get your wings do you get your
wings at the end of primary
no you got to go through three
flight schools
primary basic in advance about three
months long
and do you know that you're going to be
a fighter pilot i mean because you could
be a transport pilot yeah well
how do you how they figure out who's
going to get to be a fighter pilot
especially
at that time when i went in
if you
knew what you wanted to do
and
could convince your instructor
that you'd be a good fighter pilot
your chances were pretty good of getting
what you wanted
we needed
they were trying to build up
from
you know a few few
hundreds of pilots
to
225 000 pilots
and don't let safety get in the way of
progress
and i'd like to i don't think this is in
my book but uh
a sad um
statistic of world war ii is
we killed more of our own pilots in
training than we did in combat
wow
that's uh that's definitely a crazy
statistic especially
like the new generation like dave the
safety was number one
100 right
yeah i mean safety is a huge thing
you did say something i wanted to ask
about though
didn't everybody want to be a fighter
pilot or they're guys that actually
wanted to fly other airplanes
uh i think there was
an equal number of wanted to fly
multi-engine gotcha
um
and i don't know where my fighter pilot
thing came from actually
i think it was watching the um
battle of britain
newsreels
you know wow
and
then i thought you know
if i'm a fighter pilot and a single
place
fighter
i'm responsible for keeping me alive and
i'd be the pilot the navigator the radio
man the gunner the
bomber bombardier all of those things
and then i would not have to depend on
10 more
crews out of 10.
and besides that i thought the fighters
were a little bit cooler
well i mean you want to talk about the
building the aura of pilots i mean the
battle of britain if you're watching
that thing happen and you're seeing
those spitfires and the spitfires going
out there and doing their work that had
to at least start the momentum going for
fighter pilots becoming what we now know
as fighter pilots
[Laughter]
so once you do get trained you go you
get sent to uh san francisco and you
start flying a p-39 for the 328th
fighter group
correct and you're flying coastal
defense
well i think that's just because we were
there
and we were flying military airplanes
and they we didn't have any coastal
defense
and so you know you grabbed what you had
and said okay you were part of it
yeah it sounds like a job that
sounds like a job they kind of need
something for you to do
and they're not sure what although dave
you threw you flew combat air patrols
over
la after september 11th right our
squadron right up right at starting on 9
11 we had a
mission starting that morning where we
were flying missions up and down the
coast
yeah so that's uh kind of similar right
my imagine it came from from not knowing
what was going to happen next you know
we didn't have a clue yeah and we we uh
stayed up all night one time because
there was a report of a
japanese fleet
you know coming toward the coast
and it was it was ours
i just didn't tell anybody
well that's not a good sign
you ended up losing your wingman
in that time frame
is that right oh it turned uh
yeah i had a wingman we were doing a you
know he was brand new and so he was just
getting checked out
and i
had him on my wing and i'm flying along
here come up a couple of navy planes
and that wasn't uncommon you know we had
a lot of navy there in that bay area too
and so it wasn't
unusual that we would
each other
and
have a little dog fight
and the two navy planes came by and
came across this and
and
started heading down
towards charges
and
i swaggled my wings like
hey wait a minute
don't don't bother me now
but that man maybe
waving my wings but hey
let's have a dog fight you know who
knows
and so
i made a
pretty steep turn into him
and my
my new wingman just just
maybe his second ride and the fighter
got in here and stalled the thing
and i watched him
go into the bay
yeah um
reflecting on that in the book you say
dying was easy
a piece of cake lots of people would die
and i so and so i suppose i began
putting up walls
i knew i had to concentrate on what i
was doing and block out the rest
jaeger wrote about that in his book how
he stayed away from people didn't want
to get close
i don't know that i consciously carried
it to that extreme but it came out the
same
if you fly airplanes drive race cars do
stunts for movies or maybe walk a high
wire with the flying wallendas
anything truly hazardous then losing
friends goes with the territory
we're talking serious stress here and
you either cope or you don't
death is a thing that you have to get
used to as cruel and hard as it sounds
from that point on
from that point on i resolved to control
my emotions no matter how hard that
might be
and you got some other um
some other things that you talk about
just about being a good fighter pilot
uh you because you're you know you're
mentioning that you got to control your
emotions you also say a fighter pilot
mentality was taking firm root now
living close to the edge
sort of went with the job
daring audacity creativity flair these
things were as much a part of being a
good fighter pilot's makeup as skill and
sound judgment and were encouraged
within certain parameters
sometimes of course we stretch those a
little the rest of the time more than a
little
you measured a pilot by his formation
flying as much as by dog fighting some
guys would weave in and out just
couldn't hold it there and some the
talented ones could stick to your wing
like paint
you'd bank and go down and the good ones
would stay right there no closer no
farther away
this was war time however and there was
the other kind too we needed pilots so
there was a reluctance to wash people
out and even more so once they'd gotten
their wings marginal pilots slipped
through not many
and almost no truly bad ones at least
not in fighters
but there were pilots that made you
uncomfortable wingtip to wingtip
chuck yeager was
in the first group of pilots that joined
us at taunt tonopah
we had only six months more experience
than the guys straight out of flying
school but that was a lot we knew how to
fly p-39s the new guys hadn't seen one
some found the transition tr tricky at
first but not jaeger chuck became the
first the yardstick by which we would
measure the rest as they joined us
several each month
jager could fly right from the start he
was pretty impressive
jager and chuck mcgee had been flying
sergeants graduates of a program for
non-commissioned officers
then someone decided pilots had to be
officers so they made up a rank flight
officer equivalent to a warrant officer
one grade below second lieutenant so
these guys were unusual what we called
blue bars after the color of their
insignia the two lowest ranking pilots
in the squadron
he was from west virginia and had a
terrible draw
over the years i got the impression that
he loved to use it never tried to hide
it practiced it for all i knew
he had such a distinctive voice he had
no trouble picking him out on the radio
and he had those eyes hunter's eyes most
of the aces could pick up far off
airplanes a little quicker than the rest
of the men but as often as not it was
jaeger spotting the enemy first and
announcing it over the radio making it
sound like the grand old opry when it
wasn't him calling him out them out it
was usually me
so that's a big deal to have that that
the eagle eyes that you guys had yeah it
really was when you think about it we
didn't have any
kind of a
um
ground control you know toward you know
many bandits at 12 o'clock you know
he had to see him
it wasn't it was incredibly important
in combat
dave you got good eyes don't you
i was uh i was given the gift of of
really good vision and so but it's not
as important now no because you just get
basically in a modern you just gotta be
able to see the screens in front of your
face right thanks
it's i would not draw a comparison of
what what colonel anderson
needed in terms of the vision but having
good eyesight even today
is a huge advantage because at some
point all the computers all the
information you were talking about even
someone on the ground telling you where
to go and where to look
eventually you have to see him yourself
and
the sooner you see him the better and
the better your eyes are the sooner you
see him so
for me
50 years later listen do you describe a
fighter pilot daring creative stretching
limits
it's the exact same way we think about
it 50 years later so your explanation is
is timeless for what a good fighter
pilot makes so it was really cool to
read that and hear that from you
now
you get trained up and eventually you
get orders to europe
you get orders to europe and again to
fast forward a little bit through the
story here and people got to get the
book to to get to all the details but
you guys ride over
to england on on the queen elizabeth all
right
so but i i it's not exactly the luxury
liner that you wanted it to be right
they pack you in there with what 17 000
guys
yeah it was something like that uh
a division
middle infantry division
plus the fighter group and yeah it's
something like that yeah it's a big
number
the air conditioning i assume wasn't
great on that on that ride over well it
was for our gis
they had to ride
24 hours on the open deck they had
plenty of air conditioning
and then 25
24 hours in the hole
yeah but i was a captain
so i got a honeymoon suite on the
fourth floor nice with 17 other guys
[Laughter]
uh and you got to be were you thinking
all about like u-boats like getting old
yeah
we had not won the battle of the
atlantic yet
and
we're taking
pretty good losses
yeah and i figured that the queen mary
and the queen elizabeth had to be
primary targets
you know that there must be a ring of
them out there off of new york
and which we'd have to go through
but you know they did that the whole war
and
as far as i know were never damaged or
anything
they were fast
and
they'd change course
you know
every
so often
they would take alternative routes
instead of going directly across i
remember we do it down by the azores on
our trip to
england
and so uh
yeah
thinking thinking
about u-boats it was was very
high on my list
yeah that's got to be scary and you know
they didn't have enough lifeboats for 10
or 15 000 people on that oh my god i
don't know whether they did or not but
we had lifeboat drills all the time
wow
uh
you end up arriving
in england
december 4th 1943
and
i'm gonna get into a little section here
you say i don't remember when or how i
learned about jack
he'd been shot down over germany on
november 13th and was listed as missing
but i don't remember how i found out
it seems clear i had a note from my
sister but i have no memory of it
i don't recall what my emotions were
though in thinking this book through
i've tried i'm certain i wrote a letter
about it to eleanor saying how terribly
sorry i was
but i have no memory of what the letter
contained exactly
and and eleanor was was jack's wife
like most men who've known combat
i can remember the finest detail the
nuances what airplanes look like in my
gun sights what i felt in the swirl of
battle
what i said to people and what they said
to me on certain days 40 odd years ago
i can remember silly things the words to
some glenn miller tunes the first points
i ever scored in a basketball game these
things are burned into me i can summon
them up in an instant
but as for things in my heart on the day
i found out my best friend had been shot
down and possibly killed no clue remains
all of that is blocked out
the screen is blank
before anyone thought up computers or
knew what delete buttons were i had one
and i punched it
that was how we all managed
on december 12th i wrote my parents i
received june's letter although it had
been bad news about jack it still was
swell to get my first male here
i can imagine how you can imagine how i
feel about it
but as long as he is just reported
missing
i won't worry about him
much later we would learn he'd survived
the bailout from his p-38 but it died in
a hospital
jack stacker is buried in belgium in one
of those sprawling white on green
military cemeteries that we americans
maintain so meticulously the cross is
all in row
he was married two weeks before he went
off to war and then never came home
like 291
130 other american boys in that war
it was just his fourth mission
so this
i mean this is jack the boy that you
grew up with the boy that you were
obsessed with airplanes with the kid
that you both wanted to go and fly
and here you are
basically almost as soon as you arrive
in england you find out that
that he's been shot down
yeah yes
um
i don't know what else i can say other
than what you just read
um was a blow
to me
but then it
we knew he was in the hospital we
learned that
and so
he had been alive
so there was some hope
you know you know drags on and on and on
and you find out he's killed
it's uh
maybe a easy way to break in on it but
it's still a blow no matter how you
slice it
meanwhile
you guys get issued the first
p-51s that are going to enter the war
and
tell me about that p51 the first time
you got to fire that thing up
well i'm going to go back further than
that when we got the
i don't think any of us had even seen
a mustang let alone fly one
and then after we got to fly or fly them
it was kind of a
do-it-yourself checkout
we would send a guy up to the port where
they were assembled
find a crew chief to
learn how to start it
and bring it back and check out the next
guy
and uh
here again i'm
i'm one of these lucky guys
about this time a group commander came
by and says hey bud we're gonna
they call me andy actually
uh
you're gonna go to the
royal air force central
flight instructor school gunnery
instructor
and
take a p-51 and fly it the course
with the p-51 instead of
a spitfire
which is what the course
was taught in
so that gave me 35 hours in the mustang
before combat
where other guys were lucky to get
two or three flights
and i make that sound
you know really bad but
it was so much better than the p-39 and
we knew it and boy we weren't gonna
[__]
but the bad thing about it was the
handbooks didn't even come with the
airplane
and so we're we're making it up
and
[Music]
and it didn't have to be that way
because the pioneer mustang group was
already in
the theater checked out
but they just didn't have a way of
passing the word to you guys
well i don't know why though
dave what do you want to know about the
p51 mustang
i'm trying to imagine that feeling of of
and i think you described it
they didn't quote tell you where you're
gonna go but you knew where you were
going oh yeah but you left your p-39s
behind yes
so did you know did you have a thought
that they were going to be p51s there or
was that a surprise when you found out
well
when when i um
looking back at it uh
uh we wondered where we would go you
know with
p39s
and
be in north africa or
south pacific where they were
being
used and so
we heard at the same time we're going to
go to england and we're getting the
brand new p51 bravo
so that wasn't a surprise
but
when we got there
not having airplanes there waiting for
us
was a little bit of a surprise
and so then that's then we learned that
oh you're gonna go up to the port and
bring bring your own airplane home
jesus
uh
and we we just we thought
once we flew the airplane
boy we didn't [__]
it was so much better than the
p-39
you know we didn't want to get [__]
bitched too much said okay guys you can
go to africa and
fly your old p-39
we love that mustang
ah it was it was a great airplane
and it was
it it
it was a perfect airplane for the
european theater
it had such long range and endurance
highly
maneuverable and
just no negative things people said oh
well it was uh liquid cool and one
bullet hole in there would
ruin your whole day well we didn't have
many of those believe it or not
and so even that didn't
turn out to be a
you know a big negative factor
and i got to say
a thing or two here that
might cannot come out clear in my book
the arrival of the mustang in europe
and
jimmy doolittle
taking over the eighth air force
made a significant
impact on the air war in europe and the
eventual downfall of germany
what was the what was what was the
correlation there
okay let's see um
in late 43
the eighth air force
with their b-17s
b-24s
had a bombing halt
they stopped doing what they were doing
and their mission you know they were
supposed to kill the luftwaffe so he
could have the invasion
of of europe
and you can't go without it
you've got to kill
the
enemy's air
and uh
the way they were trying to do it was uh
they thought they could do it alone
they thought they could go without a
fighter escort or anybody
and they forgot to tell the luftwaffe
about it and they were having tremendous
losses
so they had a
bombing hall and said okay we gotta have
escort we
and they said oh by the way the pioneer
mustang group is over here in europe
in the ninth air force which was a
tactical air force that was going to go
with the
invasion and they put the pioneer
mustang with scion to it the ninth air
force
said we understand they have pretty good
range and everything why don't we try
them so they blown the
354th fighter group the
[Music]
pioneer group to the
eighth air force and they were so wildly
successful
that the air eighth air force demanded
that they get
p51s
we're the next one coming
so we go
almost directly to the eighth air force
we were we were assigned to the ninth
for a short time
and
when we got our airplanes
uh
well then
tactics
the eighth air force was in charge and
the eighth fighter command
told us how to escort
they said we want to see you
we want you close
when the enemy comes in we want just to
drive it away
and uh
when just driving them away and then
come back
you know is this this being videoed
yes it is people people will be able to
watch your hands
fighter pilots can't tell their story
without using their hands it's
impossible
if i had to put my hands down here i
couldn't tell you we would just stop
recording
at the end
no we can see you
then they can see you and so uh
so they're tactical
we actually had
an altitude limit
we could take them to 18 000 feet
if you haven't shot him down
break it off come back up
it wasn't the way to do it as it turned
out
but
we do what we're told
and
further they were
their ideas of um
oh they had all this strategic air
commands
you know was their basic
uh thinking that the bombers could go in
didn't need help
it could destroy the enemy's war-making
capability
and the troops could just walk in
well like i said they didn't tell aloof
about it
so
[Music]
they were even so upset oh
they were bombing factories oil
anything to do with the production of
fighters or just fighters on the ground
you know
inventory
so
the the chief of staff was so upset
about it he uh
had given him several
written instructions
you've got to kill the
luftwaffe
and they just weren't doing it
so they fired the 8th air force
commander
and brought in jimmy doolittle
who had a personal talk with the chief
of staff
and he said you need to do a little
the mission is to destroy the luftwaffe
i don't care how you do it
and so
he was
well you guys all know who he is and
what
things he'd done
to do little raid shortly after pearl
harbor you know incredible stuff
blind flying
and
so he was more promotic and
he
he came down to i didn't know this i
read it in his book later
he came down to visit the eighth fighter
command headquarters
uh you know uh first time
and they walked through and they had
this thing over the door
the mission of the eighth fighter
command is to bring the bombers home
safely something like that
he said
who put that
who put that up there
and general kepner
said i don't know i was here when i got
here
and he says well tear it down
the mission of the eighth fighter
command
[Music]
is to destroy the loof off
no more eighteen thousand feet
now it was pursue and destroy that was
of official
our orders were now
you fighters you're turned loose
and you know we had felt like
we were my my first
month i guess i was over there was under
those restrictions
and we did have the feeling that you
were tired you know you had your hands
by
we wanted to get into the fight
we just
were
all so eager
it was incredible
and what that happened he turned that
energy loose
and that's actually
how we defeated the luftwaffe
we shot down their experienced test
pilots one by one
and uh by spring
oh no that's the spring of 41
41 yeah
and
[Music]
the invasion was
was planned for
six june
and
so by the you know by may
the germans could not put up a mess
against us
when we were we were putting up a
thousand bombers
and
eight nine hundred fighters maybe
you know that would be the maximum you'd
go we get those kind of
missions
and
when we were trying to do it at the
beginning
the germans would put up a big
a big fuss about it
i mean hundreds of airplanes
and
by
by may
they could not do that anymore
and that allowed the
uh invasion to start
and led to the eventual downfall of
of germany
and i credit
general dolittle
turning the fighter pilots loose
his policies
and the arrival of the mustang
of having a significant impact
on the war in europe
when you guys
took the mustang out when you're flying
it how much intel did you have
about the enemy fighters did you know
when you got that mustang up going as
fast as it could go did you think to
yourself or did you know hey the mr
schmidt can only go this fast the junker
can only go that fast did you did you
you know nowadays we kind of analyze
maybe even over analyzed the enemy but
we have pretty good intelligence about
what their capabilities are when you got
that mustang did you pretty quickly
realize you were going to have the upper
hand
pretty pretty soon i i felt like i
learned it real quick
especially at altitude
i learned later that
a measuresmith in the hands of a good
pilot down low
could give a mustang a hard time
[Music]
but i never experienced that
fortunately i guess
i'd like to say a little bit about
the pacific and then um
european theater
the airplanes in the uh
european war
we're all very close in performance
not the
twin engine ones you could just forget
them
first guy there got the most
and
uh
um
yeah where you had
we had we had it
[Music]
we're faster and could climb higher than
they were
but don't turn with a zero you know this
is what i
get i never had to but i
that's when i've
heard
intelligence
reports
therefore i'd say
in europe
the pilots made a lot of difference
whereas not so much in the
japanese theater
you you had to use tactics
you know
don't dog fight
so
i think that that that was a factor in
the
in the uh european war
where was i
no that's it you were just wanting to
point out the differences and we it's
we have to bring up uh your bird you
your bird was named old crow
after the whiskey
well i tell my baptist friends it's
named after the most intelligent bird
that flies in the sky
but my drinking buddies all know what is
named after that bourbon
and i wouldn't call it good old anymore
because it's it it's down on the bottom
shelf
it was the cheapest stuff we could find
oh yeah it's great these pictures of
your of your bird uh you know you can
see
very prominently it's painted old crow
is on there everybody knew who you were
uh you know just talking about these
bomber escort missions a little bit you
go over some of the stuff in the book
but the the bomber crew tour
was 25 missions that's something that a
lot of people talk about that that if
you're in a bomber crew you had to go
and execute
25 missions if you got through 25
missions you were done you could go home
now what's interesting is you pull as
you pull the
the thread on that number
well they expected and anticipated
that on each one of these big bombing
missions there was going to be four
percent losses
so what does that mean you take somebody
with a four percent chance of getting
shot down you multiply that times 25 and
you get 100 chance of getting shot down
is what they had these bomber guys doing
and what's it what's even
scarier than that was that the actual
life expectancy the actual
number that you would get shot down on
was between 12 and 14 missions so the
four percent was a low number
now
interestingly my great uncle who i'm
named after his name was george greten
my middle name is greton he was a
bombardier in the 306th bomb group and
he he was uh he flew in a b-17
which was known as tar heel peggy
and tar heel peggy
was shot down on april 24th 1944 and
this was right when you were flying
in that area i don't know if you flew on
that day
but he was shot down april 24th 1944
there was 10 crew members on board as
you were talking about five were killed
and five were killed
five were
made it out parachuted down
became pows that actually includes my my
great uncle george gretton he was a pow
and he survived prison camp
and eventually came home but that job
that you guys had
to go and protect these bombers that
were going in and you you mentioned a
little bit of the scale
uh here's the scale of some of these
missions that you all were doing there
was there was this operation
which was called operation argument
which you refer to in the book as the
big week that started it so the big week
on one of these one one mission this is
one mission happening
417 b-17s hit one set of targets
314 b-17s hit another set of targets 272
b-24s hit another set of targets
so so right there you've got what's
almost a thousand bombers heading in
and they were escorted by
p38s
668 p47s and 73 p-51 mustangs
this
this like level uh scale of combat is
something we can't my generation dave's
generation we can't even comprehend what
it means to have a thousand aircraft
dave what was the most number of
aircraft you had in the sky over iraq or
afghanistan the missions that it was
probably a big one was in the 20s 24
airplanes i was a mission commander for
24 airplanes and that was a handful
so what does it look like when you're in
the air
with
close to 1500 or 2 000 aircraft
well
the beast the bombers would go in they'd
take off real early in the morning
assemble
and then
get
get lined up and all start climbing at
the same time
and
especially in the winter or
cold temperatures up there
we'd leave that
intense
what the hell am i trying to do oh like
uh trails contracts
and uh they would last
you know they were long
and last week sometimes we made our own
overcast with
all these things
uh then the fighters
joined them later
[Music]
you know
we could see him we can see him for a
hundred miles you know but get up on top
of
the last overcast and uh
and so we went ahead we had a heading
and he would arrive up there and
hopefully at the
proper time
but if it wasn't
you remember on the tails of the b17s
they put these big letters
squared d
a
big big letters
we would join see what the letters were
and then fly up and down and find ours
god it was
it sounds
it sounds hard but actually when you're
doing it every day
it wasn't so bad
you know just kind of routine go up here
okay
oops that's not ours
you know go up here and there go back
and were you would you be assigned to
one bomber or like a group
how many how many would you would you
and your team be covering
well
that's a good question but they flew in
a little three ship vs
and there'd be about 60 of those
60 more 60 more 60 more
and um
uh we would
god i don't know recovery just justice
how many how many different radio
frequencies would you have
for four different radio frequencies
and you just flip from channel to
channel
was there a common frequency how can you
have a common frequency with a thousand
or two thousand aircraft well that was a
emergency channel got it and
everybody in his brother was on it
that must have just been like filled
with chatter the whole time
yeah that was really
and then you had a bomber fighter
then we had our
our own channel
and we used that
sometimes to come home we did we'd get a
steer
we'd uh
we'd get a practice steer you know
what's what do you mean by that what's a
practice steer
just terminology but what does it mean i
don't know what it means dave you know
what it means
i think he's talking about giving you a
vector so so you knew which way to go to
get back to where he needed to be yeah
and he wouldn't want to say it he didn't
yeah you wouldn't want to say
i really need this now you know it was a
practice you don't want to admit you're
you need a heading so here you go give
me a practice here and then you go i
want you to go 1-8-0 and and that was
them telling you how to get home without
having to admit it oh
okay
uh you probably uh
use somebody else's voice when you're
asking for those practice tears so you
didn't sound like yourself
um
yeah it's just hard for us to even
imagine a 2000 aircraft in the sky what
do you when you're when you're flying in
what's your first indication how do you
know it's how do you know the enemy's
coming is it the first the anti-aircraft
that starts to come up the akkak no you
got that all the time
it just happened whenever they fell flew
over or
uh
from the wrong place
and is that just a matter of chance
whether it hits you or not some
the fighters we didn't we didn't worry
too much about the flack
that was
that really was
after the uh
bombers
but they would shoot at us
uh too
you were talking one time about looking
off in the distance and and it looked
like little gray puffs of smoke you'd
see hundreds of airplanes and you and i
guess probably chuck yeager more than
anybody but you could see the enemy
aircraft coming
but it didn't look like airplanes at
first i think your description was
almost look like little clouds
yeah
and it used to be that was a little
hunter chip cloud
no that's another thing that
you know that we had to get used to
in practice
we were lucky to to um
sometimes get four ships up to practice
formation that was a big deal before
ship
we did a lot of two
performation training
and every day
in england
when we flew
we flew with
16 ship formation per squadron
three squadrons a lead
one over here and one over here
and uh
two spares
they flew across the channel
turn around
if they weren't needed
and
fly through two or three
layers of overcast
probably more likely than not
and
we had never
never flew
i don't i think i can remember flying in
a group formation one time
in training
were there mishaps
with
fighters hitting each other and american
fighters and bombers just on the way
over to the target did that happen or
with it was it pretty well coordinated
guys figured it out really fast
it was pretty good
considering
but
my own flight i lost a wingman
two flights here
and
climbing through
and somehow these two guys drift
together
one of the worst ones i ever saw was
uh
b-17s you know how you can have days
when you can
look down and see pretty good
but you can't see forward
well there was a lot of those
and
we see these two columns of b17s
we're sitting up here
and they're going along at the same rate
so you can see it looking down yeah
and they're same altitude
and they're going
and they got a mission recall
canceled a mission
and these guys went like this
oh my god you could see it coming you
know
nothing you can do
you know they lost about four airplanes
right there
that was a hell of a sight to see a
bomber go down
i mean
yeah
to us
oh
you you um
going to the book here a little bit and
when you're you're now flying you say
we were fighter pilots
flying the damnedest
fastest most lethal airplanes anyone
ever dreamed up the forward line in
defense
of the entire free world
we were 22 years old give or take two
years and carrying the entire war on our
shoulders and doing a pretty good job of
it too
to judge by what the new newspapers told
us
we were winning the fight and developing
egos that would make mussolini look
humble
we weren't like other people at least
not in our own minds
we were bolder braver smarter more
spirited
better
our eyesight was keener our reflex is
quicker we were risk takers too who
worked and played hard
we were confident self-reliant able to
stand on our own and proud of it
most of all we were motivated aggressive
only the fittest and most competitive
survived the training and then the
deadly winnowing out imposed by our last
and best teacher the german air force
i was no fighter by nature at least not
with my fists i can count the fights of
my youth on one hand
but i enjoyed competing and racing cars
or dueling with airplanes was a way of
compensating for my slender build and
testing myself against anyone
i enjoyed combat which is not quite the
same thing as saying that i enjoyed
killing combat was exciting addictive a
test of our medal in manhood a crucible
in which men became a cut above the
ordinary
we thought that we we thought we were
that and we were encouraged to think it
all through our training because we
couldn't have done what we did without
thinking it
why else would they have let us fly
under bridges and buzz people's houses
it took a big ego to fly to berlin with
anything resembling enthusiasm
we were never afraid most of us anyway i
truly believe that scared sometimes
you'd have to be stupid not to be
concerned respectful
but never afraid the way a little kid is
afraid of the dark or the way you might
fear some dark alley knowing something
is there waiting for you
we were so young i suppose we just
didn't know any better
combat is like a near miss in an
automobile it happens and you react
instinctively to it and later on you
might say
that was close and your fingers might
tremble a little but while it's
happening you don't pause to assess it
and say my god i'm going to die here
there simply isn't time you just do what
you have to do
i never saw a man crack not in our group
i don't remember anyone standing down
because he was what we called flak happy
there was a guy who lost a brother and
wept openly every so often about it
but he flew he did his job
nobody had to be lifted out of his
cockpit frozen up staring
stress at least in our corner of england
wasn't what hollywood might have you
believe although it was there
no denying it
so there's the attitude
you know you point something else you
point something else out in here i had a
violet right yes sir
this is like i have to deal with dave
all the time on this stuff
the description couldn't be better it's
written perfectly
you also mentioned in the book and i
don't think i have it marked out to read
but you talk about how when you look at
the films that they made
after the war
all the pilots are 30 30 30 years old or
35 years old
you know in the in the famous world war
ii fighter pilots
and you say it was a bunch of kids that
were 20 21 22 years old
yeah
that's right
i'm gonna go to a little combat here
flying skill i've always felt meant more
in europe than it did in other theaters
where the airplanes had different
differing strong points the p-38 was
successful in the pacific although it
couldn't turn with a zero because it was
much faster when diving its pilot could
attack from above and then keep going
and the zero had no chance of catching
it same with the p-40 earlier on
the farc wolves and messerschmitts had
more speed the pacific tactics wouldn't
work on these aircraft and the p-38s was
much less effective against them to beat
them you had to turn with them like i'm
turning with this 109 right now
northwest of hanover we're flying in
interlocking circles but on differing
planes
descending we pass one another once
twice
three times at ridiculous angles with
neither of us in a position to fire
i feel like i'm gaining but not very
much and i'm excited and impatient and
getting terribly frustrated that i can't
get a shot i've worked the angle down to
where our paths are crossing at 40 to 60
degrees
what you want ideally is 0 to 10 with
the enemy either moving almost directly
away or coming almost straight at you
anything over 30 degrees it's almost
pointless to shoot with a fixed sight
of course these same numbers this same
geometry problem are probably running
through the mind of the mr schmidt pilot
i'd been considered a rather good
marksman in the p-39 and t-6 at both our
gunnery school and later at the raf's
now i've flown nine missions triggered
my guns only once and still have no
kills but i'm cocky enough to try
something bizarre
i decide to pull my sights through the
german keep pulling my nose up until i
can't see him then fire hose him and
hope against all odds that he flies
through the stream
what the hell worth a try
i pull up and fire off a quick stream of
tracer as he disappears underneath me
and another for luck
i ease the stick back and he flies back
into my view hot damn he's spilling
coolant back into his slipstream i got
him
got a goddamn golden bb on him
punctured his radiator or severed a
coolant line got my first kill
and while i'm whooping like i just
scored the touchdown that won the rolls
bow rose bowl he throws the canopy off
and bails out
his 109 goes straight in exploding
that's your first kill right there
still putting a smile on your face
you haven't read the rest of it there
you all did well yeah after this a guy
sneaks up on you but luckily it's it's
another p-51 right
yeah
yeah i uh what happened afterwards
i felt
oh you know
golly hearings a guy he's flying close
formation with me right now he pulled
right up there
pretty quick after the
the kill
and he's down low he had his mask off
and he was grinning and he gave me
something like that you know or
i don't know i didn't and i thought wait
a minute
did he shoot that thing down out from
under me you know
and i thought
my shot had to be the luckiest shot in
the world you know
to be able to
blindly
get that lead
and then see him come through
so
all the way home i i convinced myself i
probably did not shoot that airplane
down that he got it
and it was johnny england england air
force base that was the guy that the
base was named
for and so i get home he's in a
different squadron
and i
get home
i make a claim to the intelligence
officer briefing
and then i said but just hold it i gotta
go get confirmation from
a guy that
obviously saw what was going on
so now i'm riding uh
going in the g port or the officer's
club can you tell who the other pilot is
or you just know what squadron he is no
i knew who he was oh so you could see
him you're that close to him you look at
him yeah no it's johnny england yeah
what's up his mask and i could see his
name on his airplane he already had two
kills
and so
i think how am i going to bring this up
you know
am i going to say hey you [__]
did
oh you could you could bleep this out
you're good you're good
we're amongst friends
hey [__] did you shoot that thing
down out from under me
[Music]
or you know
just how am i gonna
put it to him
so
i go in the officer's club and he's over
here
he sees me and he comes running over to
me
and he says andy
he says that was the best shot i've ever
seen you got that guy out there about 60
degrees angle off
i said oh johnny you know
lucky shot
and as soon as we were through i rushed
to my phone and i got my first kill
there you go
did you guys put the did you guys put
the
the swastika on you're playing the
little mini swastika for a kill very
quickly very quickly hell yeah
oh that's awesome uh
you got a section in here um
that it's about another dog fight and i
i believe it's probably the one you
remember the best you you um it's called
the straight up encounter oh yeah
and i've got to read this this is just a
incredible um
situation here and i'm going to go to
the book
i am in this steep climb
pulling the stick into my navel making
it steeper steeper
and i'm looking back down over my
shoulder at this classic gray me109 with
black crosses that is pulling up too
steeper steeper the pilot trying to get
his nose up just a little bit more and
bring me into his sights
there's nothing distinctive about the
aircraft no fancy markings nothing to
identify it is the plane of an ace as as
one of the dreaded yellow noses like you
see in the movie some of them did that i
know but i never saw one and in any
event all of their aces weren't
flamboyant types who splashed plane on
their paint on their airplanes to show
who they were
he was someone who was trying to kill me
is all
so i'm looking back almost straight down
now and i can see this 20 millimeter
cannon sticking through the middle of
the fighter's propeller hub
in the theater of memory it was enormous
an elephant gun
and that isn't far wrong it is a gun
designed to bring down a bomber one that
fires shells as long as your hand shells
that explode and tear big holes in metal
is the single most frightening thing i
have seen in my life then and now
but i'm too busy to be frightened
and i am extremely busy up here hanging
by my propeller going almost straight up
full emergency power which a mustang
could do for only so long before losing
speed shuttering stalling and falling
back down and i am thinking that if the
mustang stalls before the messerschmitt
stalls i have had it
i look back
and i can see that he's shuddering on
the verge of a stall he hasn't been able
to get his nose up enough hasn't been
able to bring that big gun to bear
almost but not quite
i'm a fallen down dead man almost
but not quite
his nose begins dropping just as my
airplane two begins shuddering
he stalls a second or two before i stall
drops away before i do
good old mustang
he is falling away now and i flop the
nose over and go after him hard
we are very high by this time six miles
and then some and falling very very fast
the messerschmitt had a head start
plummeting out of my range but i'm
closing up quickly then he flattens out
and comes around hard to the left and
starts climbing again as if he wants to
come at me head-on
suddenly we're right back where we
started
a lot of this is just instinct now
things are happening too fast to think
everything out you stare with your right
hand and feet the right hand also
triggers the guns with your left you
work the throttle and keep the airplane
in trim which is easier to do than
than to describe
any airplane with a single propeller
produces torque the more horsepower you
have the more prop will pull you off to
one side
the mustang i flew
used a 12-cylinder packard merlin engine
that displaced 1
649 cubic engines
that's 10 times the size of the engine
that powers an indy car
it developed power enough that you never
applied full power sitting still on the
ground because it would pull the plane's
tail up off the runway and the propeller
would chew up the concrete
with so much power you are continually
making minor adjustments on the controls
to keep the mustang and its wing mounted
guns pointed straight
it's a little unnerving to think about
how many things you have to deal with
all at once to fly combat
so the mr schmidt is coming around again
climbing hard to his left and i've had
about enough of this my angle is a
little bit better this time so i roll
the dice instead of cobbing it like
before and sailing on by him i deserve
decide to turn hard left inside him
knowing that if i lose speed and don't
make it i probably won't get home
i pull back on the throttle slightly
put down 10 degrees of flaps and haul
back on the stick just as hard as i can
the nose begins coming around
slowly slowly
hot damn i'm going to make it i'm inside
him pulling my sights up to him
and the german pilot can see this
this time it's the messerschmitt that
breaks away and goes zooming straight up
engine at maximum power without much
alternative
i come in with full power and follow him
up and the gap narrows swiftly
he is hanging by his prop night not
quite vertically and i am right there
behind him and it is terribly clear
having tested this theory less than a
minute ago that he is going to stall and
fall away before i do
i have him
he must know that i have him
i bring my nose up he comes into my
sights and from less than 300 yards i
trigger a long merciless burst from my
brownings
every fifth bullet or so is a tracer
leaving a trail of thin
smoke marking the path of the bullet
stream
the tracers race upward and find him the
bullets chew at the wing root the
cockpit the engine making bright little
flashes
i hose the mr schmidt down the way you'd
hose down a campfire methodically from
one end to the other not wanting to make
a mistake
the 109 shakes like a retriever coming
out of the water throwing off pieces
he slows almost stops as if parked in
the sky his propeller just windmilling
and he begins smoking heavily
my momentum carries me to him i throttle
back to ease my plane alongside just off
his right wing have i killed him i do
not particularly want to fight this man
again
i'm coming up even with the cockpit
cockpit and although i figure less i
know about him the better i find myself
looking in spite of myself
there's smoke in the cockpit i can see
that and nothing more
another few feet
and then
he falls away suddenly left wing down
right wing rising up obscuring my view
i am looking at the 109s sky blue belly
the wheel wells twin radiators grease
marks streaks from the guns the black
crosses
i'm close enough to make out the rivets
the messerschmitt is right there and
then it is gone just like that rolling
away and dropping its nose falling
almost straight down leaking coolant and
trailing flame and smoke so black and
thick it has to be smoke or oil
it simply plunges headed straight for
the deck
no spin not even a wobble no parachute
and now i am wondering
his ship seems a death ship
but is it
undecided i peel off and begin chasing
him down did i squander a chance here
have i let him escape
he's diving hard through
he's diving hard enough to be shedding
his wings harder than anyone designed
those airplanes to dive 500 miles an
hour and more and if 109s will stall
sooner than the mustang is going
straight up now i am worrying
mate that maybe their wings stay on
longer
at 25 000 feet i begin to grow nervous
i pull back on the throttle ease out of
the dive and watch him go down
i have no more stomach for this kind of
thing and right now
not right now not with this guy
enough
let him go and to hell with him
straight down he plunges
from as high as 35 000 feet
through this beautiful crystal clear may
morning toward the green on green
checkerboard fields leaving a wake of
black smoke
from four miles straight up i watch as
the mr schmidt and the shadow it makes
on the ground rush toward one another
and then
finally
silently
they merge
i think i just found a guy for my
my audiobook
i know how you feel
that's just um
yeah
dave what's your breakdown of that it's
give us give us a breakdown i i'm
actually just
i'm kind of at a loss for words and i
know this sounds maybe even sounds a
little arrogant i can picture what he's
saying so even when he's talking about
he you're right here sir even when
you're when you're talking about looking
down your wing line seeing his nose come
up to you and you know
if he's got two or three more degrees on
you which is which is kind of like a
matter of inches really in an airplane
that he's going to get
that this messerschmitt's going to get a
shot
and the the sinking feeling that comes
with seconds later the elation of
watching him shudder and you know that
he can't keep his turn
even the angles and the fault so
your ability to get another pilot to see
through their eyes what you're seeing
is
it is it is remarkable how well it is
written in a way to describe it
so i can feel what you're seeing not
just see it it is just unbelievable to
listen you describe that
and then the shadows you know merging
with the airframe and then at your
altitude it's probably a fireball but
you don't hear anything
and everything in between there is just
i have never seen something written
well enough to see it with my own eyes
as what you wrote in that dog fight
um
it's it's really amazing for me to hear
and i'm really grateful that you have
the ability to get that on paper and
capture that forever
we
may blame uh
joe ham joe hamlin yeah well
he he didn't fly the airplane i know
that well the stories are all mine
and when it came to
oh
we first had to get together
and he'd go home and write
a couple of chapters and then we would
uh
come back and review him and i said joe
this word isn't even in my inventory
you know
and
we'd go on and on not to say i don't
even know what that means
and
we had that and then when it came to the
flying
he would try it and i said
joe
give me a yellow pad over there
and i'd write it all out
long hand
i said don't change a word
and
but after we got together
so many times
he really got into my head and he did a
marvelous job and
and uh
and then
even when i said don't change your word
sometimes he'd
try
and i might or might not leave it
because
he was a he is a good writer
absolutely
i would have taken my book and say
i was born on january 13 13th 1922 blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
you know
but you know the way he mixed
mixed it through the book right i think
was really good yeah no that's so that's
the just for everyone that's listening
that's the the the co-author of the book
that helped write the book
um joe hamlin did a great job
when
when you're so when you're looking over
your shoulder at this messerschmitt and
they're start he's starting to stall so
you can see that you can see the plane
start to kind of shake i said
i see him shutter right but
i don't think you can see it shutter
shutters a feel in the airplane you know
you feel it
but there's some visual thing that's
going on that you go over well
you know
that's the beginning of a stall
and you can probably sense when you're
about done going up too so you knew that
you were close
and then when you're shooting
that that aircraft
you have to make little micro
adjustments with your nose to get like
you're saying you hose it down like you
would a a campfire so you're making
little tiny adjustments to kind of sweep
up and down on that aircraft with your
maneuvering
you know maneuvering was maneuvering is
just a little bit of rudder yeah that
small amount
you had to keep it in trim
and um what i mean and trim keep the
ball centered
if you had a ball
off
then you're sh you know you're shooting
and the airplane's over here
you can't you gotta
you can't
oh so this makes whereas normally you
could get away with having trim be off a
little bit because you're still just
maintaining some kind of a bearing but
in this situation if your trim is off a
little bit your gun's pointed in the
wrong direction right might be you know
and you've got you're making these
constant micro adjustments and i
actually
that's a part of the book that i didn't
quite go into the deep level of detail
that you have to do to keep that trim
but i failed to understand why that's so
important in a gunfight when you have
fixed sights because
like if you're flying an aircraft i mean
i've taken off in air small airplanes
before where there's a strong crosswind
the plane is going if you look at the
heading of the plane it's like 10
degrees off the direction you're heading
but you're still going in the right
direction
so if you do that with your gun that's
going to be a problem so you've got to
keep that thing perfectly trimmed all
the time
dave you didn't have to do any of that
well he had a computer doing all this
for him well we
we got the early computers
you had it harder than i did because in
a jet moving the throttles in a jet
doesn't change your trim
every time you move the throttle in a
propeller you change the torque
every movement of a throttle and i have
a little bit of propeller time i learned
to find a propeller airplane every time
you move the throttle forward or back
you have to adjust the rudder trim so
when he talks about the ball we called
it stepping on the ball which is a
little literally a little gauge that has
a little white
background and a little black floating
ball that would tell you if your nose
and tail are aligned
it'd be like pointing a gun with your
wrist cocked in one direction or another
every time i move the throttle on the
jet the computer said we're okay don't
worry about it the ball is always
centered every time in a pr prop you
have to either use your feet or use the
rudder trim so when he's talking about
moving the throttle what he's not saying
is that every single movement of that
throttle meant moving my feet moving
with my thumb moving my hand so the the
intricacy to be able to track
a an me109 that's probably what 30 feet
long and 30 feet wide
the the accuracy to do that is so
precise to be able to do that in a
dogfight like that is so hard to do
i got the colonel here's like the
humblest guy in the world saying joe's a
good writer which i know he is
but he didn't track that me109 with his
p51
the way that you did so i still just
it's remarkable that you're able to
capture that and and i'm trying to do
justice to how
difficult that is and how intricate that
physical movement is in your airplane
also the fact that you describe this
one-on-one engagement that's something
that i always loved as a fighter pilot
was ultimately at the very end what it
would come down to you and somebody else
but what's hard for for me to really
truly grasp is that there's a war going
on around you you weren't the only two
airplanes in the sky at that time so
your ability to compartmentalize and
focus on this one airplane as part of a
much larger thing going on is all to me
equally as remarkable and the thing is
that
what we call
situational awareness
you have to do that you have to know
and i've got a real good example of when
we were doing a dog fight
i saw a
shadow
and
when we were through i said hey guys you
see anything
shadow or anything no no no
okay come on down and
get lined up here
i said i knew what was going west
generally speaking and
so i go along here
pretty soon
we come up and i see the shadow again
before i can see the airplane
and it was a bright sunny day
and it was a green on green
uh
camel
and if it'd been hazy i never would have
seen him
and so
i could come up and it's heightened 111k
all obsolete
battle of britain bomber
and uh
we had a gunner we silenced the gunner
and we got both engines spoken
and so i scored much i i went back over
here on the
from this side to that side
and i'm scoring them as like as they
shoot
so that's how you get a quarter of a
kill and share the whole thing
and my number four guy's a new head you
know new
inexperienced guy and he
he fired every round
on one pass
and you could imagine where the bullets
were going
it burned the barrels out you know
and we only had 30 seconds of
of
gunfire
yeah that's not not much i know
and uh
you come home a couple of times within
no way i'm old
how many seconds did you fire up that
messerschmitt on the in the straight up
encounter
three four five seconds something
something like that
yeah that's still a lot of rounds to
receive i don't want to be the receiver
that's 50 cals
uh
you go on here
talking about that straight up encounter
you say eddie simpson joins up with me
both wingmen too simpson my old wingman
and friend had gotten the one who'd
climbed out this is another aircraft
we bagged three or four three of the
four we were very excited it had been a
good day
i had lived and my opponent had died
but it was a near thing
it could have been the other way around
just as easily and what probably made
the difference was the airplane i flew
made in america
i would live to see the day when people
would try and tell me that the united
states can't make cars like some other
folks do what a laugh
i didn't wonder if i just made a new
bride a widow or if he might have kids
any more than i would have wondered
about a snake's mate and offspring
i may have given some thought to how
many of my friends he had killed or i
might or he might have killed in the
future or how many bombers he might have
shot down had he lived
but that's as far as it went
from what i could tell he hadn't been
overly concerned about me
people ask about that all the time
people usually ask it hesitantly as
tactfully as they can but they ask it
did i wonder and worry about the mothers
and childrens and wives of the men i
shot down
did i carry any guilt or regret
no not then and not now
world war ii was a total thing
us against them when being against them
was unquestionably the right thing to be
i flew from my country and was proud i
could help in any way that i could
besides all of my opponents were trying
to kill me
and frankly
i always was elated they hadn't
this one had almost gotten a beat on me
he'd come as close as anyone would
when it was done 480 hours of combat
flying in p51s and another 25 missions
or so in vietnam almost all of those in
f-105s
i never once suffered a hit in
air-to-air combat
the sum total of the damage all my
aircraft absorbed amounted to one small
arms round that found one of my wings
during a strafing run after d-day
it bored a hole the size of my little
finger
it didn't even go all the way through
just punctured the underside skin
nobody noticed it until the next day
needing a patch the size of a coin
that's exactly what my crew used a
british shilling
people on the ground often shot at me
flak batteries machine gunners foot
soldiers with rifles and pistols there
may have been some who threw rocks who
can say
but this man on that day was the only
opponent who was ever behind me and he
couldn't quite bring me into his sights
and he never did fire
to my knowledge i was never i never was
fired upon by an airplane in combat
skill had something to do with that i
suppose
but there was certainly something more
to it than skill
lots of hot pilots never came home
i guess i was lucky
or blessed
yeah that american-made p-51
was just next level in the sky huh when
you guys were getting that thing it must
have seemed like you know a lot of times
for me you know i grew up
i grew up the the p51 was like an
antique right it was like an antique
thing
but for you guys this was like a piece
of
the newest technology imaginable
yeah
just a just an incredible bird
i i mean dave
that's like you getting into an f-22 or
an f-35 for the first time it is
i i can't imagine you know
certainly the prominence of that
airplane but it had to feel good to know
and i
fully appreciate and i'm so glad you
wrote about it what it always came down
to was the man in the in the cockpit
that's the ultimate
factor but it had to feel good to know
you were getting into an airplane
that was gonna
level the playing field or give you an
advantage over what the germans had so
you didn't have to mitigate the
deficiencies of that p-39 or something
else that had to be a confidence builder
to say if you want to go fight me
one-to-one
any in up-down left-right any
environment this airplane will be just
fine so
that feeling of getting into that p-51
knowing you're going to war had to be a
lot better than what you might have been
flying in anything else
and i felt that when i got in my first
fight in f22 no i felt like
i'll fight anybody anywhere how did that
happen how did you get
being a marine i wanted to do that if i
can steal a line from your book
i was very lucky
yeah a lot of timing a lot of just good
fortune a lot of things right just align
the right place right time need
requirements qualifications and at the
end it's really hard for me to take
credit for being the only marine that's
gotten to do it
but i was very lucky you're the only
marine that got to fly the f-22 ever
[Music]
and the and the f-35 those marines at 5
30. yeah i was the first marine only
only marine to ever fly the raptor first
marine to fly the f-35b you know as
operational how did you get how did you
get in the raptor
short version of a long story the marine
corps was going to buy f-35s it's a
whole new airplane they didn't know
how challenging it would be to go from
old to new we hadn't done it in 30 years
the air force had just introduced a new
fighter called the f-22 to replace the
f-15
and they basically sent to spy go live
with the air force for three years and
learn all the lessons that they've just
learned
from going from the f-15 to the
we'll take those lessons and apply it as
we replace the f-18s with the f-35 so i
got lucky to be selected for an exchange
with the air force to learn all about
the f-22 all about this new generation
and all about the challenges of
replacing a 30 40 year old airplane with
a brand new airplane because the marine
corps hadn't done it since the early 80s
and i was the guy that got to do it and
i went straight from the f22 to the f35
lucky yeah you two need to play the
lottery
so look i'm i
i'm not going to read the whole book you
know you've got a bunch of other
encounters in here
dog fights
incredible detail on the combat
experience
you end up with 16
kills 16 and a quarter 16 and a quarter
that's right don't let me leave off that
quarter what what was the quarter four
was the quarter for that one that you
just described yeah so there you go you
got a little bit of that one too
you end up with 16
uh kills you fi you fly your last
mission
with jaeger
you guys are out there together okay
um
and again people get the book it's
incredible get those details
but i'm going to go back i'm going to
skip forward a little bit here
and you say
i hadn't intended to get married it just
kind of happened i landed in the states
on february 1st 1945 and married my pen
pal
the widow eleanor cosby stacker 22 days
later
it took me a few days to get from the
east coast to california
and i know i asked her at least a week
before we got married
figure it out the courtship lasted no
more than ten days to two weeks pretty
intense
we were married three days before chuck
and glenis
it didn't sit all that well with our
folks our moms didn't think it would
last and you can understand why
after we've been married about 20 years
with our two kids almost grown
my mother poured it all out to eleanor
she told her i thought you'd run home to
mama at the first sign of trouble i
couldn't have been more wrong you're a
wonderful person they had a good cry
at another time elle's own mother told
her the same ellie had been married to
jack for two weeks
and had mourned 15 months
people thought she was vulnerable
but she knew her own heart
after 40 plus years were still happily
married no question she's the best thing
that ever happened to me
over the years we've seen lots of
couples break up
loving a fighter pilot is like loving a
cop he leaves for work in the morning
and you're never entirely sure he will
come home at night
worse there are inescapable agonizing
periods of separation where the woman
has to be both father and mother to the
children keep the house together manage
the money and contend with the
loneliness
and there never is much money
but we can look back and laugh now
surviving the trials is what brings
people closer
i ended up with 70 years
she passed away
and
that's not in the um
it that's a updated version didn't it um
i'm not sure which version it is i know
i have two versions here let me see the
color uh the cover to this one i think
that's the original yeah
i think this is the original one i think
this is the updated one oh okay yeah i
have both versions
yeah well actually one of them's dave's
version that he's had for 20 years or
something
what can i say about that the storybook
romance right right
no it's um and then what
what was it like coming home and you i
didn't mention this it's in the book you
you actually came home for a little bit
of leave in between and you got treated
like the biggest hero in the history of
america yeah
which is awesome
uh
but when you're now you come home again
for good for for for good so to speak
well yeah what you didn't know it would
be for good maybe you would be going to
japan or whatever but germany
surrendered while you were back in
america right and
so so how did that feel
did you feel like we did it
i've
i was pretty elated
and you mentioned this in the book and i
think it's definitely worth talking
about
so
the 357th
who you were part of shot down 609 enemy
aircraft
died in training 57 were killed in
combat and that was from 16 accidents
and then the others were killed in a
shot
and there was 71
pows taken
you had 28 original pilots in your crew
in your group
nine of whom were killed seven of whom
were shot down and became pows
yeah fifty 50
ah you must have felt very lucky to be
home
um
but then it's like you're you're looking
at japan right you had to be looking at
japan like everybody else yeah
it was always there yeah
but but you ended up going to texas and
did you become a flight instructor
was that your job in texas yeah but i
led a group
you know
i had a group of instructors
and uh i'm i'm a
group commander
and i ride the i have to ride the
i go to the
instructor school the central
instructor school
then come back
and
they only let me right do the wash rides
what's a what's a wash ride
tell a guy he's not gonna
make it oh you're washing him out i got
it
uh
and then it's
next thing happens is so you're there
working as an instructor and the next
thing happens is vj day
yeah
and
now the war is over
you know
what was it what was the state what was
the mindset of america on vj day
uh just
i don't know how to explain it but
extreme joy
and i don't think there's any remorse
from a serviceman that
served in
that time
about the use of the atomic bomb
and i really
truman and
he he did a good job yeah yeah
no doubt about that and especially when
you hear the stories from the guys that
fought in the pacific
on the ground against the japanese i
mean it was going to be absolutely
horrendous if we had to go into mainland
japan
yeah
and
you know they were we know they were
training their kids and the women to
fight with sticks
and hide in caves
and
we would have just wiped them out
yeah
we would kill more japanese and then
than uh
americans
yeah
um
so now that the war is over you you
going to become a recruiter
going for going recruiting duty yeah
everybody's getting out
uh
jaeger becomes a test pilot and it seems
like he eventually recruits basically
recruits you to become a test pilot well
he allowed me to he got me an interview
with the head of a flight test
uh
you got a cool section in here during
these test pilots a year test pilot
years um
scary scary and i kind of wanted to
bring out the fact of what it was like
being a test pilot because it was risky
business back then
um
this section here you say on april 24th
1950 through 1953 we took off in
rendezvous with the b-29 and a couple of
chase planes at 25 000 feet in the chase
aircraft were jake knight and bill ross
the pilot scheduled to join john on the
project i moved in on the b-29 hooked
onto its wing tip and again the dash
panel light remained dark no power damn
thoroughly frustrated by now i
disconnected moved away from the
mothership and davis moved in and hooked
up so this was what you were trying to
do what what we were trying to do as a
country was get away to make the
fighters be able to support the bombers
longer and they devised some kind of
system where you could actually take two
fighter planes
and hook into the wings of a big giant
bomber that has a bunch of fuel and
there they it would kind of pull you
along
well that was one
one
concept that
people latched on to
but the basic program
was a theory by this german engineer
that we brought back from world war ii
to work work at right field
and he
theorized that you take a
a bomber
if you could put a wing extension out
here
just
a wing extension
and you have some way of controlling it
you increase the aspect ratio
and
that gives you longer range
and so they wanted to do it in a wind
tunnel but they didn't have the priority
and all that stuff so
uh
i said well let's
let's try it with airplanes
well that was okay except we haven't
done that before
and so that's why we developed a program
with a c-47 and a little q14
and
with a
simple
locking mechanism
like
back again back into it
and then the drag would hold us it was a
beveled ring
then we had a beveled ball with a with a
dump bevel
with a spike
and
he had to go in front of it and backhand
which made it about twice as hard
and then
it was
locked when you pull the throttle back
but then if you want to get out just
add throttle to it
so as you're trying to do this you're
you try bringing your plane in you
connect but you're not getting the full
connection
and so then i'm going back to the book
autopilot coming on he radioed so this
is after davis moved in and hooked up
this is a completely different project
okay yeah so what project is this one
this was
using two f-84s
two airplanes one on each wing that was
going to be the panel right
and we had gone through the manual
flying of it
and
done
enough to give them confidence
to go to an automatic pilot
and uh meanwhile i'd been she
i'm sorry
meanwhile i'd been
i'd been there about five years which
was
way more than
normal and
i wanted to stay there and i told him i
say this project's coming up
the only other guy that can do it is
john davis he's been flying along but
just flying i flew the daily ship
that got all the data on you know angles
and speeds and
and john was flying another airplane
manually
just a
standard fighter
and so i could never get power
this was something like the fifth
fifth time
and
everybody was getting
nervous you know
they wanted progress
[Music]
and the contractor
was a low bidder
on the autopilot
um
and i'm in the pentagon now i got a new
boss
and he's pissed off at me because i'm
going away flying
they asked him
to let me go
i should have told them to stick it
so they didn't they didn't see much
desire and keeping me there when i was
when i knew this was coming up
but to one of the most experienced guy
to
make the first few flights and then turn
it over to the
check out some other guys
and uh
yeah now you're you're you're you're
coming up on the bad part yeah so
so basically you had gone in to try and
see if you could get it to work it
didn't work you didn't get the
connection you didn't get the um
the power that you were supposed to get
when you connected up to the bomber yeah
and so you break off
and then davis comes in
and he hooks up
and and he i'll go to the book now
autopilot coming on he radioed and i
knew he would be trying to set some kind
of record for turning a switch on and
off
and then his airplane abruptly pitched
up and over and smashed upside down onto
the wing of the b-29
i saw the explosive bolts of fire if a
certain angle between the wings works
was exceeded they were to fire
automatically blowing the connection
apart but it didn't matter
it all happened too fast
the spasm reaction of an autopilot far
out of phase through the f-84 over onto
the bomber like the cover of a book
slammed shut
there was no time for anything not even
a call on the radio
the outer panel of the bomber's left
wing peeled upward from the tip almost
to the outboard engine and then the f4
f-84 fell against the main spar the
impact sheared the jet's nose away
cleanly just in front of the cockpit the
fighter bounced off and fell away in a
glide i remember yelling for john to get
out but i got no response
the bomber nosed over and with the most
with most of the wing gone
fell into
big power spiral and augered almost
straight in
it wouldn't have been the simplest thing
in the world to get out of pointed
almost straight down inspiring spiraling
tightly and pressurized which would have
made getting a door open even more
difficult
earlier flights had been flown without
pressurizing the cabin guarding against
exactly this sort of incident
but everything had gone so well flight
after flight
that somewhere along the line the b-29
crew had decided such precautions
weren't necessary
in the final seconds just before the
bomber crashed into the bay one of the
crew of five struggled free
but he was too low by the by then and
there wasn't enough time for his
parachute to come all the way open
moments later the fighter burrowed into
a forest throwing up a huge fireball
six men were dead one a close friend
because engineers programming the
autopilot had erroneously assumed the
b-29s wing to be rigid
and because there wasn't an instrument
to warn us of
to warn us how out of phase the
autopilot might be
and because there were too many people
involved in the project and because
everybody was probably too much in too
much of a hurry and because no one had
fought up computers which probably could
have worked out out the settings and
because of curtis lemay had said keep
working on it and of course because i
hadn't said it's too damn tough at a
time when saying it was almost certainly
would have killed the project
in war when death is all around a man
can steal himself against it block out
the heartbreak press on
but this wasn't wartime and maybe i'd
let my guard down
maybe of all the things that have
happened to me in my life this probably
hit me the hardest
i was a long time getting over it
john davis was dead and it could have
been me probably should have been me
we never did learn why i couldn't draw
power from the b-29s
so um
horrible
incident
yeah i have to say
that uh
in all of my 30 years
of service
the hardest thing i had to do
was
drive back into the housing section
and tell a
widow that her husband's not coming back
tonight
i just uh
i had to do that so many times you'd
think i
would have coped with it
but somehow rather it just
was very difficult for me to do
well there's uh
you know you talk about this in the book
there's at one point where someone comes
comes there's so many accidents
happening someone
comes to do an assessment
of the
the program
and they say there's no evidence of a
safety program at edwards like it didn't
even
exist um
and and actually dave and i were talking
about this you you eventually got tasked
with creating uh the safety program
there
and dave and i were talking about the
term buying the farm which everybody
knows what buying the farm is but i
think we found the root of that in your
book
was that you guys used to say oh if you
if you die then your your widow's going
to get a ten thousand dollar insurance
policy which is enough to buy the farm
or buy whatever you want so that's where
from from what i know that's where that
term comes from exactly buying the farm
uh but you get tasked with
coming up with that safety program um
and
you know you're you're you're at how
long are you at that test
pilot program for forever it's a long
time
you gotta you got a pretty good story
about about uh jaeger in here
i kind of gotta read this one
uh you you're going again there's some
background and i'm skipping through the
book so buy the book to get the details
chuck was involved in the testing and on
one of the flights
in late 1963 i was practicing
instruments in a t-33 just happened to
be in the air listening on the radio
when chuck's chase plane had a problem
and had to abort
i piped up and said hey i'm available
all a chase pilot does is follow as far
as he can and then pick the man up
coming back and stand by to help if he's
needed so you're out there just doing a
normal flight chuck's doing some kind of
a test flight and his the person that's
supposed to be observing him
something happens to his plane yeah
yep so you say hey i'm i'm up here i got
it
as i circled in the general area where
the nf104 would return to my altitude i
listened and watched
chuck made a level run
then lifted the 104's nose and touched
off its rocket blasting almost straight
up leaving a trail that could easily be
seen
at a hundred thousand feet i learned
later the 104's nose pitched up which
was always a danger in the star fighter
when you ran out of speed and reached a
certain critical angle
a device made the stick actually shaking
your hand to warn you as you approach
this angle of attack and if you didn't
correct then a stick pusher would move
the nose down automatically instead of
stalling at this angle the 104 would
pitch up gyrate around and fall into a
spin you could recover from if you had
enough altitude
only this time the air was too thin for
maneuvering and the small thrusters
didn't have enough power to force the
nose down
chuck's plane fell into what became a
flat spin belly down like a frisbee the
kind of spin you can almost forget
getting out of
he tried everything to book in the book
to recover
he even popped the landing drag chute
trying to get the nose down with no luck
i followed him down from twenty five
thousand feet circling his spinning
aircraft as we reached 10 000 i was
yelling for him to get out
he fired the rocket-powered ejection
seat and while i was calling for the
chopper to fly out and get him i watched
his parachute billow
i came over low as he landed to see if
he was all right
he was lying down and as i flew by he
waved
the way he was lying seemed awkward but
i wrote that off to the cumbersome space
suit
i came by again and he was standing up
waving
i circled until the chopper arrived and
took him off to the hospital
i was stunned to learn he'd been burned
by the time i got to the hospital his
head was swollen as large as a
basketball
as he'd ejected the seat had become
fouled in his parachute lines and the
pull of his shoot popping open had
slammed the seat into chuck
the still hot rocket attached to its
underside hit him smack in the face
splitting open his helmet his helmet's
face plate the spent rocket was still
spitting some flame and it flashed
inside his split helmet fueled by
chuck's oxygen he managed to get the
face plate open which shut off the
oxygen or it might have been worse
as it was his glove caught fire and his
face was badly seared the doctors had to
peel away the skin
daily for weeks it must have hurt like
hell you can still see the scars though
you have to look closely
so that's a day in the life of the dang
fighter
test pilots back then
uh
just kind of crazy stuff you guys were
doing
well the cold water was still on
but what he was doing was uh
trying to set out a new
official
speed
time to climb
record
and there was a specially modified
f-104 that they were going to try to use
in the test pilot school he was
running the test pilot school at that
time so
he was doing some of his own flight
testing but
we had already
flown the airplane to 120
something thousand feet
and uh
what's space isn't space fifty thousand
feet so what how how high up is space
i forget what there there is an official
yeah i think it's probably closer to
eighty eighty thousand it's definitely
about fifty i've been to sixty oh i'm
just kind of laughable by these
standards it's not space is this the
scene is this the scene that they show
in the in the book the in the movie the
right stuff and in the book the right
stuff
this this scene right here are you
familiar with that movie the right stuff
yeah
is this what they when they portray
jaeger crashing yeah and he comes
walking out of the fire
and the guy says now
what is that that's a man
i forgot that
uh
so you spend this time out there
um eventually you get signed
to the
in like 1965 you get assigned to the
18th tactical fighter wing this is in
okinawa
your son meanwhile
jim goes to the air force academy yeah
so i guess he was he was following his
father's footsteps how did you feel
about that
i was really proud of baby
i am proud of him
he's a real good guy
that's uh that's a pretty amazing story
i took him for a ride in a
f-105 he came to okinawa
okay wait how old was he when he went
for a ride in a 105.
oh
i forget what the academy oh so he was
at the academy
yeah he was a cadet
and then of course later on
he took me on a combat mission with him
well go ahead and tell us that story i
think we already did well we weren't hit
we hadn't hit record yet and i was only
catching pieces of it because i was
getting set up
so what happened how did you end up
doing a combat mission with your son in
vietnam well
he
when he got out of flying school
he wanted to go to fighters
no had
b52s you know
called out
and so he finally decided
well if i can't get fighters i might as
well go to vietnam
so he went to a special operations
squadron
this was on the
choose list
and flying an o2
which is a
push puller
cessna 337
standard 337 modified for
special operations
and
then shortly after he
got there i i got assigned to uh talk
lead in thailand and
105s
uh in the southeast asian war
and
the seventh air force was having
all commanders
meeting in in saigon
and so he would live he was a benoit so
right next door
so i called him and i said hey
maybe we could get together you know
and then he he comes back with
hey you want to go on a combat mission
with me
i said you got to be kidding
you'll never get
that permission to do that
and i
certainly would not have permitted it in
my wing
and uh so
he says stand by
and when he's a new guy
and he's standby
and he could come back come back all it
seemed like a minute later he says it's
all set
he says
uh
you you come on down to saigon
i'll pick you up the next morning
we'll go on a combat mission land at
benoit spend the night
and then i'll get you back to your
your big you know saigon meeting
so sure enough
it happens
but
special operations they do all kinds of
stuff
and
um
so
he probably picked a
minimum risk kind of a
project
we we went out
the um
the the o2 had a
loudspeaker on it
and they'd go out over
communist strongholds and
[Music]
publicio
speak um
or stuff like oh hit him with some
psyops some psychological operations yes
that's what i was trying to think about
and then
we'd
go back over the area and
drop leaflets which gave them safe
passage
they could go and you know go up and
surrender with it and we would take him
up as a
prisoner with no
wouldn't kill him
well i'm glad that that approval chain
didn't go through your wife because she
was not
very happy
i i
i i carry this story
i'm a little overkill when i do it you
know
oh you know
i can't
i don't have the words i can't describe
what it means to me to be able to fly
with my
son in a combat mission i certainly
wouldn't let anybody do it in my
organization
and
then i go on i say but
my word my wife had a few words to say
about it
she's damn glad she didn't know about it
until it was all over
um
yeah
speaking of like flying with your
friends and whatnot
uh you had a little reunion
in vietnam as well here's another one
you got chuck yeager chuck said well we
flew our last combat mission in world
war ii together we might as well fly our
first combat mission in southeast asia
together
that morning we served as a crew for one
of several bombers on a close support
mission making one run after another
over an endless green jungle
a forward air controller on the ground
with a radio gave us targets and we dive
in 30 degrees pretty steep for a plane
of that size toggle away a single bomb
then fly back around and let go another
over and over again ever so carefully
trying to put them right where the
troops wanted them
again we stayed the night and partied
with friends so you got to do ops with
with jaeger again in vietnam
you know
uh
eventually you end up with um
eventually you end up with the you
become the commander of the 355th
tactical fighter wing
and you're flying the f-105
uh thunder chief which dave told me
is is called the thud
and how'd you like that bird
oh yeah i don't know what thud beans oh
okay dave gave me some bad intelligence
you didn't call it thud
[Laughter]
no it got that name from
crashes
in the development of the airplane got
it and after
after after it was deployed even the
first few years
and i remember when i went to the um
18th wing
they were putting in
safety pack 19 and 20 and 21.
god
it had a terrible reputation but
i have to say
about the 105
once we got all the bugs worked out on
it
it was a very reliable airplane
and it made a good bomber
you didn't want a dog fight with it
except with another 105.
uh
they called it a fb you know a fighter
bomber
uh
i flew a tour
or a part of a tour in southeast asia
with it
after we'd not quit going north
we were bombed just bombing the hotend
ho chi minh trail
uh
you talk about that uh deployment to
vietnam
and what that was like
uh it's i mean we had pretty good air
superiority compared to compared to when
you were fighting the luftwaffe over
france hell that's for sure
um
and and eventually your jets get sent
home
because you had a bad relationship i
believe something happened with the thai
government because you were in thailand
and something something went wrong there
oh and it wasn't um
it was near the end of the war
and so they decided to send the strike
thuds
you know the ones making them bombing
strikes
sent
one of the groups home
and unfortunately it
it was my group
i got in the pentagon
when i left okinawa
i thought
i'm combat ready in the airplane
next logical place is to go to southeast
asia but i'm a bird colonel
and those assignments are more difficult
good good assignments
i said no you're going to the pentagon
i didn't want to do that
and i guess my grumblings
got down to the colonel's assignment
somewhere and so
i got a call he says hey we got a need
for a
colonel who's been a wing commander
who's checked out in the equipment
and your name flashed out
i said yeah that's what i wanted to do
when i left okinawa you know
and uh said well if you want to take it
you can take it
i'll take it and
then he said well i got to tell you
something bad about it
it may close while you're there
maybe shut down gonna
send the wild weasel airplanes home
no keep them
and send the uh strike eagles
strike
not the eagles thuds strike that's home
so
nobody knew what to do the
state department said oh
you cannot close that wing at this
moment
and uh
we went in there with a
just a handshake
we didn't
normally when you go into a foreign
country
you have a status of forces agreement
where they
give you example cases like
one of your truck drivers kills a
a tie in an accident what do you do
and we didn't have any of those
we went they thais wanted us in and we
we wanted him so
we went in
anyway
we got all these things the thais wanted
uh
every
they wanted everything including the
airplane
but uh when the time came
we start shutting down
but still with no
no um
no end date you know when did we
when did we
shut down right
state department was the point was the
problem they were
and christ's
ties were still
shipping us bombs you know driving
truckloads of bombs
they go through the tie gate and get the
[__] you know
and they didn't want to turn off the
bombs so they're bringing them to us
we're stacking them in the road
you know the shelters are all filled you
know so we're stacking them in the
goddamn roads in the
jesus
just
you know violation or regulation after
regulation
and
not have any luck at that
got a
seven-day force
seventh air force
assistance team came to visit us
help us shut down
and so i said well we only need one
thing
give me a date a shutdown operation
well we can't do that right now
well you could stop the bombs from
coming in
and
the four star turns to a colonel and he
says
take care of that
and we got the bomb
shut down
and i'm still on date
and uh
i learned i learned a few things during
this period of time
it was i'm going home to a mandatory
retirement
and uh
uh i won't tell that story let's see
they offered you a billet in saigon and
you said nah
i'm not gonna sit around here i'm a oh
after yeah yeah after they shut it down
yeah we're still closing the base down
oh i can tell you that okay i'll tell it
to you
you have another meeting well i think
was the same meeting that i went down
there to fly with jim
and this
young brigadier general arist
in operations
was
was at this dinner and
something came up about me going to the
headquarters
and he pipes up yeah i've got chose you
it'll be good for your career
so i said in the loudest voice i could
gracefully do
oh then you know i go home to mandatory
retirement
yeah really good for my career
[Laughter]
god
damn so
you end up going home uh go ahead
on closing base
i said uh
i took i had seven full kernels
i says you you
close you make a plan to close your
function
you know from
day one if i tell you
how many days
weeks whatever
does it take you to shut down
and so i said every one of you do that
and then give it to me
i put them all together added two months
and picked the date
and uh
then i decided to put it in a telegram
to all ships at sea and everybody i
could think of
and state department everybody
and
title
close your
close the
closure of talking plan
something like that
and i set that thing in and sat back
and i had no idea what i was going to
get
and oh christ we got a plan it'll work
like
it it it like we're like magic yeah we
we call that leading up the chain of
command we're gonna make this happen
jesus christ
yeah everybody was so happy except
except the state department
but i learned a lot of things about
um
waste in government
so
we tried to get rid of everything we had
and
what didn't we couldn't
went into the trash
and went to the ties
and
so
one morning they came and told me hey we
got a dead tie officer in the
such-and-such building
it was one of the buildings we were
cleaning up but we had not turned it
over to the ties yet
and
he was in there tearing out the electric
wire
electrocuted himself
they were you know selling it to them
but about to trash
so
steel
lockers labor intensive to tear up tear
down
very heavy
if i tore down
tore him down
shipped him home nobody would have said
a word but it would cost like hell
but if i put them in the dump
aha
government waste look at this
but what we did was
south vietnam
had a great they needed them badly
so i said well if you send somebody over
here and dismantle them and get your
c-130s
i got tons of them
and so we got rid of most of them that
way
some of them did make it to the dump but
it was a hell of a lot cheaper than
packing them up and sending them home
and nobody would complain
there you go you got to find those
solutions yeah
so you end up
getting orders
back to mcclellan air force base which
is which is about 90 minutes from auburn
which is where you're from
uh this was sort of what we call i don't
know if you call in the navy we call it
a twilight tour
this was sort of your twilight tour you
get put in charge of maintenance you
still get to fly t33 so you're happy
about that
but this is sort of this is where you uh
end up your career
right
and i'll go to the book here
you say too soon
it was over
there was talk about a big ceremony but
i asked them to forget about that and
just mail me my papers
there was a short sweet ceremony in the
commander's office ellie her folks and
my mother were there and that was it
30 years and 30 days from my day of
enlistment at age 50 i was a civilian
again
going out in the place where it had all
begun
my mother had actually written
the epitaph for my career a bit earlier
when i'd flown home from talk lee
well she said when i walked through the
door
are you satisfied now
i said sure
file it under white lies
uh because that's you know you can never
be happy never be satisfied
um
and that was the end of your career in
the in the air force you ended up
working for mcdonald douglas
well a mcdonald aircraft company and
later make mcdonald's
got it they would say bottom hour
uh you took a few years off from flying
but then you started missing it you
started flying again
uh you got some great stories in heroes
when you got
a version of old crow back
in one of these restored
p51s you got to fly that you got to fly
with jaeger
again in some of these air shows
just
again the stories as the book closes out
and and how it goes and the rest of the
stuff you've done just
great just incredible story incredible
story
uh how'd you feel that day you when you
retired
i had mixed emotions
i know so in the seal teams you know you
have we call it a drying cage but it's
basically a big locker probably the size
of a prison cell
but you have all your gear in there all
you gear in there that you collect for
the years that you're in and i was in
for 20 years
but i remember my last day i got my van
downstairs
and i and for me it's kind of similar in
that
18 out of 20 years i was stationed in
coronado in san diego
all within a hundred yards
seal team won
seal team three seal team seven when
seal team seven was
was in a old building right next to seal
team one and then the training command
they're all
100 or 200 yards apart that's where i
spent my whole adult life
and then one day
my last day i retired i went up cleaned
out my locker
my gear cage
threw all that stuff in my van and left
and that was a pretty empty feeling when
i left because it's your whole life
uh so i'm sure you had some of that when
you when you got done oh yeah actually
that
comment was made by my mother
was made when i
was retired
and after i was retired she said
well you satisfied yet
now
well tell you what this is probably a
pretty good place to stop um
the book has so much more detailed
information in it
you know
it's just an incredible life
incredible hero and i got to read one
more quote from the book you said
you said all those years
they'd actually paid me to fly
what a deal
it's just uh
incredible
dave you got anything else
i'm sure you guys could talk for hours
i'm sure you are yeah
it's this has been
this has probably been one of the best
three hours of honestly of my entire
life getting to be here and
you know i'm lucky
i get to work with jocko i'm on this
podcast a bunch and i've gotten to meet
so many
veterans and then and then now you know
this movie top gun just came out again
and it's so prominent and and people ask
me all the time
you know what was the first movie like
and i saw that i was 13 when the first
movie came out so as you know at that
age when you see something at that young
age you look at it and you think man i
really
want to do that and a lot of times when
people ask me you know why'd you become
a pilot i i think about that movie a lot
but
as a little kid you know much before 13
14 i was reading books
and i remember as a little kid
reading a book on on papi boyington and
reading a book on on the black sheep
squadron there's a tv show you know
long before top gun i was i was already
i was already enamored
already enamored and it was it was
jaeger
anderson
foss
and boyington and what i've realized in
this podcast as i'm listening to your
talk when i was a little kid
what i wanted to be was you
i wanted to be you
and i can't express how much gratitude i
feel and how much reflection i have now
as a very little boy long before the
movie top gun ever came out is what i
wanted to be was what you described in
this book and to get to sit across from
you and hear you talk about this
uh is just an honor of of my lifetime
and i can look back now and when people
ask me why i wanted to be a fighter
pilot
i can tell them that i got to meet the
reason why so thank you very much
this has been awesome thank you
yeah i don't have much to say after that
dave um
you know
uh
i get asked
you know what do you what do you
tell
kids today
and
what i tell kids today is
you know you really can be what you want
to be and
there's a good example of it right there
if you want to be something
really really bad
you can be it
and
i say
to kids live your dreams
and
find a
finder something you like to do
and if you
can
if your job is something you like to do
you can excel
in that job
and um
live your dreams
that's that's that's what i
say these days
well sir uh you certainly lived your
dreams without any doubt and uh you know
people can find you you got a website
oh yeah same name as the book it's to
fly and fight dot com is a dot-com yet
to fly and fight.com so anybody that's
interested in hearing more about you
hearing more of your story you can go
there and
check that out i mean it's just uh it's
incredible it's an honor to be sitting
here
talking to you and and to have dave here
just it's incredible to see
so thank you so much for for joining us
and and making the effort to come out
here and of course more importantly
thank you for your service to our great
nation
thank you for what you did in combat to
defend
the world from tyranny and from darkness
and to defend freedom in the world
you fought
machine against machine
and you fought man against man
in the ultimate test of skill
and you won every time
and and that's pretty impressive and we
salute you and we thank you for your
service sir
thank you very much
and with that
bud anderson
has left the building
dave i feel like i should just turn it
over to you at this time i don't know if
that's a good idea man i i need a little
time to decompress and kind of
contemplate that that was um i knew that
was going to be a unique experience for
me but that was
i don't have a lot of frame of reference
to what to compare that to that wasn't
that was unreal for me man
when he just stepped up you were kind of
rattling off some of the thoughts that
you had in your head
as you were thinking about this
and you're thinking for instance
a thousand aircraft go out
and
whatever
six hours later
10 of those are gone
100 aircraft crews gone
this is what they did day after day
after day after day yeah
uh
there's like i don't know is there
anything equivalent for a fighter pilot
to being a world war ii fighter pilot
look the guys in vietnam obviously
extremely challenging uh you know
horrible situations to go and going into
you know having
guys like charlie plum and william
reader on on the podcast to talk about
their experiences
you know
surface-to-air missiles migs out there
uh those encounters were
relatively rare
compared to you're going to bomb germany
you are 100
gonna get into it yeah this is the next
level yeah i don't think from scale like
there's nothing
he's talking about
was it big week is that what they call
it big week yeah first mission thousand
bombers 800 fighters and 16 160 germans
come up to fight him something like that
so there's 2 000 airplanes in the sky
and
250 bombers don't come home
i don't think there's anything certainly
in my aviation mind that's even close to
the scale of that it's just it's hard
even for me it's really hard to relate
to what that might look like it's kind
of overwhelming
the heavies dude
hey by the way they just mentioned this
if you want to get the book to fly and
fight go to go to this website i already
mentioned to flying fight.com
and
bud
is signing books so you can get a signed
book
from that website and
i would recommend you do it i mean this
guy's a hundred years old right now just
he the stuff that he's seen in his life
lucky to be here
um just awesome so if you get the chance
and the book by the way i i read through
two dogfights
so there's
whatever 14 more
and they all have their own little
details they all have their own little
scenarios that are happening and look
the rest of the book there's all kinds
of things in there that we didn't talk
about
so
if you want to hear that story go get
that book to fly and fight.com
we may have to like once this comes out
actually when you listen to this again
take notes and maybe we'll do sort of a
a a wrap up of this and you can kind of
talk through some of the stuff and maybe
even bring in some different stuff from
the book if we didn't cover it because i
mean you're talking about
them shooting down german uh
german pilots that were parachuting and
that was just there's a bunch of other
things to talk about that we didn't
cover here yeah so when you listen to
this take notes and maybe we'll do
another sort of a recap or an after
actions on this even if it's just like
you know
an hour or four or whatever
right on we can go through it uh echo
charles you've been here the whole time
but you've been quiet yes because you've
been uh you didn't have a mic
yes so on purpose what you know let's
face it what am i going to add to well
then again i did kind of have some there
that first dog fight
you know what wait the first one or the
one the first one that you read okay one
that he he said lucky yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i
i was
so a lot of people say like oh you
should read my audio book or whatever
but that was the first time where i was
like you should read this audiobook
you meaning him or you meaning me you
okay so because and of course the
story's laid out like perfectly yeah
right especially at the end i don't know
why i like the end so much when he was
like oh i don't even know if that was my
shot it might have been the other guy's
shot you know and i don't even know how
to approach this guy and then when he
found out it was his that was good
yeah you know i didn't i actually didn't
read that part so he could kind of tell
the story and it's a weird thing to try
and figure like what do you want to read
and what do you want to hear from them
yeah and you got about i mean in my mind
i'm always trying to think like i want
to give them enough that they go oh yeah
and they get in the zone and then they
kind of fill in the deets as they say
yeah
but man
you know it's such an honor to be able
to have these guys on and
hear their stories man it's just
it's crazy and then you know you always
have to think to yourself
that
there's almost 300 000
that didn't come home from this war and
that didn't get to tell their story and
didn't get to have kids
um yeah it's just
so we're so lucky to be able to to have
this opportunity to do this so um
i appreciate y'all listening and and if
you want to support what we're doing
here and you want to support yourself
too which is a bonus that's true some
people might even prioritize supporting
yourself over supporting what we're
doing here either way it's a win because
if you support yourself good
we i want you to be stronger and smarter
and faster and better yeah
one of the functions of this the
existence of this whole outfit i think
yeah so if you want that
you can go if you want to support you
want to support yourself you want to
support america by the way you can see i
kind of got a little fired up when we
started talking about the p51 mustang
the p51 mustang was like the
it was a game changer a game changer 500
miles an hour just faster and stronger
and better it was american-made
it was american-made and and
obviously it was american-made but just
think of like every detail that the
engineering the design the material like
all that went into that and that that
that wasn't even an idea on december 7th
1941 that wasn't even an idea they're
just like okay cool we have to build the
best you think well i actually don't
know the history wasn't an idea yet
i don't know exactly the development of
it they knew we knew we needed better
airplanes but i don't think anybody
certainly in 1941 could have predicted
what the mustang was going to be
other than we needed something well i
was so fired up listening to talk about
the mustang that i started thinking
about the ford mustang like i just need
to get a ford mustang because i can't
get a mustang mustang i can't get a p51
mustang but i can get a ford mustang
that's an american-made piece of
machinery legit legit
that's how fired up i was getting
talking about
this aircraft
and uh what they did with it
so
america if you want some american-made
stuff well first hey jocko fuel got
jockofield.com go get some stuff hey
jocko fuel we got all new flavors i was
pounding mine today were you pounding
yours today dave how's that new orange
it's so did you think your orange could
be better i didn't know that it could be
better
it's like the p51 mustang of freaking
drinks it's the upgrade it's like the
new version of the mustang is just a
little bit better it's a little bit
better yes and echo charles how are you
over there on the mango
actually i got messages saying that
that's their new favorite flavors you
got people mango comes through more yeah
so their old favorite flavor was mangoes
and their new favorite flavor is mango
is that what you're saying their old
favorite
flavor apparently was not mango i'm just
guessing what the last one was
nonetheless yeah they're all they're all
a lot better they're all a lot better
they're different they're they're in a
different category so jockofuel.com get
yourself some more get yourself some
joint warfare some krill super krill
uh origin usa look made in america is a
thing and peep like you know like bud
anderson said people like oh we can't
make the stuff over here i laugh at them
that's what pete roberts did when they
said hey you can't make ghees in america
he laughed at them
because guess what we can we have the
capability we have the technology we
have the skill set we have the will to
get it done
and look you can go buy your you can go
buy your your jeans let's say
from a place that is literally has
slaves
you can that's what you can do or you
can buy it from america
where
we're on board with freedom
with freedom that's what's happening
and they happen to be the best jeans
that i own
[Music]
the next modification or the next
version of the genes i don't even know
what they might we might do but
there's going to be some p51 things
coming out
and look i get it p38 love it uh corsair
love it you probably love the corsair
all the time i do because you cause
that's marine corps
wait what's your is that your favorite
bird world war ii when i grow up like
pappy boynton black sheep
marine corps corsairs winning the war in
the pacific yes listen
the p-51
is the iconic world war ii fighter and
everybody knows it that doesn't mean i
don't love the corsair all the marines
out there know what's up but listen the
p-51 that's the machine that won the war
in europe everybody knows it bro
sometimes the the p51 flies like in the
vicinity of my house because they'll do
the coastal runs and i can hear them and
then you look up that the the silhouette
look the cool thing that's cool like it
would be a little bit difficult to tell
a corsair from the side profile you know
when it's out at a little distance you
know
but at p51 you see that bottom air scoop
you're like there it is
big daddy's coming home
uh so if you want the if you want the
p51 mustang of american made
gear
go to originusa.com and get some
american-made stuff that's going to go
out in the world kick-ass is going to be
faster better stronger we got hunt gear
coming you probably saw just me wearing
my hunk here have you seen the pictures
of the camo in the in the in the
environment as they say so of course
they did yeah made a big deal out of it
made a thing out of it yeah that's good
wait you oh yeah you made a predator
quote
revisited it but it was good it passed
it landed you got there all right so
good it looked good though yeah it does
it does it's awesome uh jockofield.com
originusa.comstore.com yeah that's what
echo made
we well you know it was a collaborative
effort for sure but yeah we got some new
stuff on there what do we have standard
issue discipline equals freedom shirts
standard issue there's a layer in there
there's layers and couple layers in
there and they're optional layers you
don't even have to know the layers to
appreciate the the garment as it were
um so yes
get that we didn't this is like the what
second announcement on the podcast we
made we didn't make the official
announcement yet so oh for the for the
standard issues freedom yeah we'll
probably announce it like next week or
whatever but if you're hearing this boom
get yours before everybody you're
already in there yep also short locker
subscription shirt every every week
there's a good one coming two good ones
coming oh yeah you showed me the draft
of one of them this is the kind of thing
people are gonna want that one i think
you're right about that one i feel that
way please tell me there's gonna be
something
in the future themed on the p51 or
something for the sherlock come on the
p51
look i like i said the p51 has always
been
up there in my head
but i mean let's face it it went next
level today it went next level today and
you know what reading the book
i mean you think about that you think
about your climbing as hard as you can
in the aircraft and you got a
messerschmitt 109. by the way germans
world-renowned for their engineering and
their their efficiency with their
building of their aircraft the whole
nine yards
and you're like guess what i'm from
america
sorry bro
i'm i'm from america i got a p51 mustang
with what how many uh 1100 horsepower
something crazy
and we're gonna go you you're gonna hang
with me cool see what you got
hanging by the propeller he used that
term a couple times hanging by the
propeller you can imagine that thing
just trying to grab air
and it's just about to run out and that
thing
freaking epic dude
it's true um yeah so yeah there it is
short locker don't forget that one sign
up for that one
sign up for that jacquardstore.com yep
subscribe to the podcast subscribe to
jocko underground.com
people look we don't control these
platforms look we talk about freedom a
lot there's some people that are
offended by that they've kicked people
off of platforms
for what they've said
so we don't want to risk that
everything's been cool so far we hope it
continues to be cool but if it doesn't
we have jockowunderground.com eight
dollars and eighteen cents a month if
you wanna help us build that and
maintain that
check it out and look if you can't
afford that it's okay we still want you
in the game as they say if you can't
afford the eight dollars and eighteen
cents a month to support no factor email
assistants at jockowunderground.com we
got a youtube channel i'm the assistant
director for these youtube videos sure
clearly clearly that's the difference
bro
and i thank you thank you for that
praise praise
uh
psychological warfare we got
flipsidecanvas.com dakota meyer put
making cool stuff to hang on your wall
books for once again to fly and fight by
colonel
clarence e budd anderson with joseph
hamlin as the co-author
just go to to
flynnfight.com order that book up
check out some of the other books we got
we got only cry for the living by holly
mckay that's choco publishing right
there
she she she risked her life to read to
write that book
so and it gives you an insight it's not
too often you get the insight of both
sides of a war right
not not historical like hey this was
a hundred years or 30 years ago this is
like oh the war is going on right now
and we're hearing both sides
so that's what holly did
so order up that book
final spin
i wrote a novel
look i've written a bunch of books too
so if you want to get some of the books
that i've written get some of the books
that i've written get about face i
didn't even write it i wrote the forward
on it i'll tell you what i don't even
know sometimes i read that book
and i just think i just my life
every podcast should just be about
another section of about face
there's so many things in there it's so
filled with
goodness that you miss goodness
right it's like you walk into a buffet
and maybe over in a corner there's like
some some uh
some little wagyu beef like
niblets right hell yeah but there's
prime rib over there there's some you
know some bacon wrapped hot dogs over
this is like a bunch of stuff you missed
the niblets bro like no more room on
your plate kind either that are just
overwhelmed with so much yeah almost
goodness everywhere yeah maybe they got
some mold like in the containers you
ready to drink you know we got ready to
drink milk coming yeah rtd as they said
that's the word
i
was worried not worried you you you you
want to control your expectations right
you want to be like look it's going to
be healthy there's no sugar like
it you know how can the it's going to be
it'll be good but how good
dude it's
gtg as we say yes it's good to go ea
all day
it's delicious yeah i was comparing it i
would i wanted it to taste as good as a
certain um let's say known well-known
brand of chocolate flavored drink we'll
say okay we're there
that's good that's good yeah that's
interesting it's outstanding imagine
drinking something that is completely
good for you and it tastes delicious i
don't know i mean i guess
oh yeah and
and i said this from the beginning where
my kids like the the you know how this
working monkey whatever they like the
regular one like the best they think
that's like a treat and i kind of
psychologically like train them to know
that that's like the treat or whatever
but yeah and so i know i don't
guilt-free you know there's something
that you can do that tastes so has so
much goodness so much
so much immediate gratification and no
downside
short and long-term pain yeah
that's kind of a
i guess you could look at jocko fuel
from a strategic perspective and one of
the consistent
underlying themes of the
products
is
short-term
mega-gratification taste-wise and
long-term total goodness across the
board health-wise yeah that's a thing
it's an anomaly people people don't know
what's up with that it's kind of hard to
believe in a lot of ways yeah wait a
second
as dave said earlier today what i should
say is you're welcome
dave's like choco you just need to tell
people oh here's my drink you're welcome
oh here's molk you're welcome he was not
wrong with that here's joint warfare
take it you're going to be able to do
things you couldn't do two weeks ago
you're welcome oh but then again i don't
know joint warfare's pills
i know but you're welcome yeah
for sure media yeah okay the short term
let's face it that's like what do you
call it what do you call when it's like
normal yeah you know something that you
don't love but it's like the standard so
we're going to shut it down echo good
work what thanks man any other cool
things i'm saying that you want to kill
i'm keeping it what do you call uh uh
real like down to earth like for you
know yeah you see what i'm saying nice
job
appreciate it okay let's just end this
for you not go screwed it up bro what
have you been talking about
it's all true we're just riding this
huge wave you're like yeah but those are
pills
okay you know what we need to do we're
gonna make some chewable oh the season
warfare now you're talking about have a
really good like lemon lime sort of zing
to it tastes good okay remember back in
the day old school or more or less
uh same generator remember those vitamin
c wafer
okay see now we're talking this is those
vitamin c wafers is is how you end up
with 3 500
milligrams of
vitamin c in your day oh yeah colds are
running away from yeah
and they they tasted kind of like like a
special candy 100 you know oh yeah see
so that's like the
the the avenue to pursue as far as pills
go yep i don't mean pills you know what
but let's face it let's look into it
yeah as eddie bravo would say look into
it
uh hey we also have echelon front our
leadership consultancy we solve problems
through leadership
if you need help inside your
organization
with anything it's a leadership issue
so go to ashlandfront.com
for details on that we also have some
events you can come to
next thing we have next big thing we
have we have other things that are sold
out in the meantime but atlanta october
12th through the 14th then that is the
next muster we're going to hotlanta
actually in october hopefully it won't
be too hot in hotlanta should be all
right
but that's we're going to be so if you
want to come
check that out
and also we have an online
training academy
it's extremeownership.com
and if look leadership is not something
you get good at in one day
you don't go to one seminar just like
you don't go to a jiu jitsu seminar and
say okay cool i'm ready to take on
gordon ryan now yeah right now it's not
gonna happen not really but you can
grab individual things from time to time
and roll them right into your game that
day you can do that you can do that and
that's that's one of the things that
happened at the muster but you better
have a game and you better keep training
that's what the academy is for
extremeownership.com all kinds of good
stuff going on on there
on top of that if you want to help
service members
active and retired you want to help
their families gold star families check
out mark lee's mom mama lee
i just talked to mama lee yesterday
yesterday was august 2nd
mark her son was killed on august 2nd
2006 it's been 16 years since he was
killed in action
and that whole time almost actually no
not even almost from the word go
mama lee
looked to help
she helped the platoons she helped the
task unit she wanted to make sure we
were okay and she hasn't stopped that in
any way shape or form she's doing a ton
of things to help out veterans to help
out gold star families
america's mighty warriors.org
is
her
website and if you want to donate or you
want to get involved go to that website
also heroes and horses.org micah fink is
up there in the wilderness
and he sent me a message the other day
and he's got i i'll i'll get the
complete message but it's basically a
person that he's working with that's
like a counselor a high level counselor
said
that he had never seen
changes as significant in human beings
as he has as he had seen
the the guys that went through micah
fink's program going in the wilderness
for 41 days riding horses eating meat
cold baths
he's got all kinds of things going i
want to go too much into it but if you
want to support that go to
heroesandhorses.org
and if you want to check us out on
social media we're on there but let's
let's listen
we're not in the algorithm well they're
going to try and put us in the algorithm
but we're we don't want you to get
caught in the algorithm but if you want
to check out what's going on with us
dave is at david r burke echo is at echo
charles and i am at jocko willing again
watch your six
to use the the flight term watch your
six watch your back so you don't get
caught
in that algorithm
and
finally to all those uniformed personnel
out there
thank you for fighting for our freedom
with a special salute to the airmen i
don't know if this is right dave is
airmen in the army navy air force and
marines all those what do you call
people that work in the air air dales
they're still marines huh they're
marines
well to all of you
that own the skies
you all have your own aviation units
inside all the service branches and as
much as i love the ground pounders and
the doughboys and you know i do
uh it's you all
up in the sky that cover for us on the
ground
so thank you for your service and
sacrifice and also thank you to our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
all the first responders
thank you for your service and sacrifice
as well and for protecting us here
on the home front
and to everyone else out there there's a
part in this book
where bud is talking to his
granddaughter's class
and it's 40 years after the war
and one of the students asks
something like what is the hardest
thing
about being a pilot
and without hesitation he replies
losing friends
and we get to read this book
and we get to hear
about the life and experiences of bud
anderson but
as i said earlier just remember that
there are
hundreds of thousands of stories
that we never heard
lives that were cut short
in the sky
on the ground
and at sea
brave souls who sacrificed everything
for us
let us never forget
those heroes
and let's make sure
we are living lives that honor that
sacrifice
we owe them
at least
that much
and until next time this is dave and
echo and jocko
out